CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE COMMITTEE.
BUT ISN'T CHEN WE LIKE TO BE TO
TAKE CARE OF SOME HOUSEKEEPING
FIRST WE HAVE ONE ITEM ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR TODAY THAT'S
ITEM NUMBER. SEVEN EIGHTY SIX OH
EIGHT LISTEN CHEN THE COMMITTEE
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO ADVANCE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB SIXTEEN
OH FIVE FOR THE BUDGET CHAIR
BUDGET YOUR TEAM.
SO THEY CAN GET INTO BRIEFINGS
BEFORE WE DO THAT AT WE'RE GONNA
INVITE ME SITTING THERE TO COME
FORWARD WELCOME SIR WE'D LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO A SOUR ESTABLISH A
QUORUM AND THEN TAKE ACTION ON
THE KITCHEN COUNTER.
MISLIM CHESTER CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
YOUR REQUIRE PRESENT MORE LOCK.
WELL I PRESIDENT BELL.
HERTZBERG FURTADO.
HELLO PRESENT NIELSEN.
NIELSEN PRESIDENT WIENER.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE A FOUR IS ZERO
VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT ROLE
OPEN WE WANT TO SAY
CONGRATULATIONS TO MISTER TITLE
WHO IS BEEN A LONG STANDING
WINNER OF THE RICARDO LARA AWARD
AND I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
CENTER WIENER TODAY'S SO -- GOOD
STUFF.
THEY SAID YEAH WE LIKE TO BE TO
JUMP RIGHT INTO THE COUNTER A WE
WANNA TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO MISTER TING FOR OFFICE
WORK ON ALL ISSUES OF THE BUDGET --
AND WILL TAKE CONTENT RIGHT
AFTER THIS SO WE CAN GET INTO
WE'LL TAKE IT RIGHT NOW ALRIGHT
WE'LL TAKE CONSENT.
MS LANE CHESTER ROLL CALL PLEASE
REQUIRED BY WIRE I'M MORE A LOT
MORE LIKE I BILL HERTZBERG.
RICARDO.
RICARDO ALL RIGHT NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER.
CURRENTLY A FOUR EIGHT ZERO
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH REMEMBER TING
WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE HERE
THIS IS THE CRICKETS THREE
RENOVATION IN PRICING PROGRAM.
THANK YOU MISTER FOR ALSO ALLOW
ME TO TO GO FORWARD AHEAD OF OUR
BRIEFINGS I A. B. SIXTEEN OH
FIVE IS A DISTRICT BILL IT
ALLOWS THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO TO CHARGE.
A RESERVATION AND PRICING
PROGRAM TO BETTER CONTROL
TRAFFIC ON ONE OF THE MOST
FAMOUS STREETS NOT ONLY IN OUR
CITY BUT REALLY OUR COUNTRY THIS
IS THE ONE BLOCK OF LUMBAR
STREET IS THAT IS QUITE CROOKED.
AS AS YOU MIGHT BE WELL AWARE --
IT IS A MAJOR TOURIST ATTRACTION
ON BUSY WEEKENDS WE GET
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND PEOPLE ON A
CITY BLOCK.
ON IT THAT THERE IS SERIOUS --
TRAFFIC CONGESTION AS WELL AS
PEDESTRIAN OVERFLOW IS QUITE A
CHAOTIC SCENE WHO WE ARE THE
CITY IS.
ASKING FOR THE AUTHORITY TO BE
ABLE TO CHARGE A RESERVATION
SYSTEM -- AND THEN THEREFORE
POTENTIALLY CHARGE A TOLL FOR
THAT CRICKET STREET IN ORDER TO
BETTER MAN.
THE ON PEDESTRIAN AND TRAFFIC
OVERFLOWS SPECIALLY DURING THE
BUSY TIME OF YEAR.
AGAIN IT'S OUR DISTRICT BILL
IT'S ONLY THE LONELY ASKING THIS
FOR THE CITY COUNTY SAN
FRANCISCO FOR THIS ONE ROAD AND
AYE AYE SIR TO START OFF BY
SAYING AYE AYE.
EXCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S WORK WORKING WITH US
AND ACCEPT THE A SEVEN YEAR OF
SUNSET DATE.
I AM THE DOCTOR JUST TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I DON'T
HAVE TO TAKE A TAKEN QUESTIONS
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL AND THEN I THINK THE
OTHER ONE IS JUST MAINTAIN THE
ACCESS. FOR THOSE WHO CANNOT
ACCESS THE CRICKET STREET AS
PEDESTRIANS AS WELL SO GRATEFUL.
TO SIMILAR TING FOR ALL THE WORK
ON THIS BILL WITH THAT CAN NOW
OPEN UP TO FOLKS WHO LIKE THIS
WE CAN SUPPORT.
WELCOME MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PAUL
YOUR ON BEHALF OF THE CITY AND
COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO -- IT'S FOR
THE BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WOULD LIKE TO BE RECEIVING WHAT
ELSE IS HERE FOR SUPPORT
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
MORNING TEARS AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I AM AND YOUR HUDDLED
WITH THE SAN FRANCISCO COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH MANY OF THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY GROUPS ON THIS
ISSUE FOR THE PAST FORTY FIVE
YEARS NOW -- WANTED TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AS WELL AS
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED --
THIS IS A VERY BUSY TOURIST
ATTRACTION -- SEES OVER TWO
MILLION VISITORS A YEAR TWICE AS
MANY AS MUIR WOODS BUT THERE'S
NO WAY RIGHT NOW FOR THOSE
VISITORS.
AND WE'RE LOOKING FOR THE SYSTEM
THAT'S PROPOSED AS PART OF THIS
BILL TODAY -- TO MAKE THIS A WIN
WIN FOR THE RESIDENTS OF THE
NEIGHBORHOOD AND FOR THE
VISITORS TO THE STREET ITSELF
RIGHT NOW -- IF YOU VISIT THE
CORPORATE STREET AND A CAR IN
THE BUSIEST WEEKEND YOU'RE
WAITING IN LINE FOR OVER FORTY
FIVE MINUTES -- TO GO WITH WHAT
IS ESSENTIALLY THREE BLOCKS
THROUGH THE LINE -- SO -- WHAT
THIS BILL WOULD DO IS AS IS AND
THE RUSSIAN ALLOW THE -- SITTING
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO TO
AUTHORIZE THE ABILITY -- TO
REQUIRE A RESERVATION WHICH WILL
HOPEFULLY SPREAD OUT -- THOSE
ARRIVALS VEHICLES SO THAT THE
WAIT TIME IS REDUCED TO LESS
THAN FIVE TO TEN MINUTES THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH VERY
GRATEFUL YOU'RE HERE TODAY PRE.
DO APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
WHAT WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BE A TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL?
CURRENCY NINE WE NOW LIKE TO BE
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
OPPOSITION VAGUELY SET FOR THIS
TIME [inaudible]
LAST CALL.
KERN SAYS IN OPPOSITION ANY
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR WAS
SOMEONE LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
ADVANCE MOTION SIR VICE CHAIR.
I'M JUST CURIOUS MISTER WHAT
PREVENTS THE CITY FROM DOING IT
NOW WHY DO WE NEED TO DO A STATE
LAW PLEASE SITTING I'M I'M I
UNDERSTANDING IS BECAUSE WE
COVER THE THE VEHICLE CODE ON
THE TOPIC AT WHICH A PART OF
STATE LAW IT IS BUT THEY THEY
NEED.
AUTHORITY FROM US TO DO THIS.
BECAUSE BECAUSE THE STATE LAWS
GOVERNING THE THE ROAD
[inaudible]
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
WITH SOMEONE LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
ADVANCE A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY CENTER
DOESN'T THINK SO MUCH IT'S
SENATOR THIS MOTION IS A DO
PASSES A MINUTE DESCENT
TRANSPORTATION.
SOME NUMBER TEN WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSER.
THANK YOU FOR THE ACCOMMODATION
APPRECIATE YOUR I FELT GRATEFUL
SIR AGAIN THANKS FOR ALL YOUR
MANY MANY HOURS -- ON ALL ISSUES
BUT EVEN LIVING THE DREAM AND
WILL CONTINUE TO LIVE THE DREAM
HERE OVER THE NEXT FORTY EIGHT
SO GOOD TIMES.
ARE I'D IS LANE JUST ROLL CALL
PLEASE WIRED HI WHY I'M MORE
LOCK.
WELL WE'RE MORE LIKE NOBEL
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible] FOR TARO.
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER.
ONE THAT IS A KERN TWO ONE
CORRECT FOUR TO ONE BUT WE'RE
GONNA KEEP THE ROLE OF AND THINK
I CAN MUCH THE MEMBER.
MEMBERS -- WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO CALL UP AS A MEMBER
JONES SAWYER.
ADVANCING AB THIRTY SEVEN WE
WILL THEN GO TO THE MAJORITY
LEADER MISTER CALDERON AND THEN
WE'LL BRING UP AS A MEMBER
PATTERSON RIGHT AFTER THAT.
JONES SAWYER THANKS FOR ALL YOUR
WORK ON THIS THANKS TO UP FOR
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE THE
FLOOR IS YOURS SIR IT'S ALWAYS
GOOD TO SEE YOU ARE GREAT TO SEE
YOU.
OUR MEMBERS I TO WANT TO THANK --
TO COMMITTEE.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL AND I ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
AB THIRTY SEVEN WILL ALLOW
CAMERAS BUSINESSES THAT FILE SO
PROPRIETORS FOR AS PARTNERSHIP
TO DEDUCT ORDINARY AND NECESSARY
BUSINESS EXPENSES FROM THEIR
PERSONAL INCOME TAX STATE INCOME
TAXES.
THE ABILITY TO DEDUCT EXPENSES
INCURRED WHILE CONDUCTING
BUSINESS AND ENJOYED BY ALL
LEGITIMATE BUSINESSES WHILE
FILING TAXES.
HOWEVER IRS CODE SECTION TWO
EIGHT OH DE PROHIBITS NON
CORPORATE ENTITIES THAT SELL
ILLEGAL DRUGS FROM DEDUCTING
THESE EXPENSES CANVAS WHILE
LEGAL IN CALIFORNIA IS STILL A
FEDERAL.
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE AS A RESULT
CAN WAS BUSINESSES THAT ARE NOT
INCORPORATED ARE TAXED AT A
HIGHER RATE.
THAN ANY OTHER LEGAL BUSINESS IN
THE STATE AB THIRTY SEVEN WHAT'S
WHAT A LINE OF CORPORATE AND
PERSONAL TAX CODE TO ALLOW LEGAL
CANVAS BUSINESSES TO DEDUCT
LEGITIMATE.
OPERATIONAL EXPENSES.
THIS BILL PROMOTE EQUITY AND THE
SUCCESS OF LEGAL CANNONS
BUSINESSES BY REDUCING THE TAX
BURDEN ON THIS NEW INDUSTRY. FOR
EXAMPLE IN MY DISTRICT THE LEGAL
MARKET IS STRUGGLING COMPETE
WITH THE BLACK BLACK MARKET
WHICH HAS OVER SEVENTEEN HUNDRED
ILLEGAL CANNABIS BUSINESSES
WHILE OTHERS. TWENTY LEGAL ONCE
IN LOS ANGELES.
AB THIRTY SEVEN WILL HELP CAMPUS
BUSINESSES IN THE LEGAL INDUSTRY
AND OUT OF THE PREDOMINANT BLACK
MARKET WITH ME TODAY I HAVE AMY
JENKINS WITH THE CALIFORNIA.
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU SIR I MEAN I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING FOR THIS
BILL I EVEN WORK IN THIS ISSUE
FOR MANY YEARS IT'S A GREAT FORD
AND CANDIDLY.
IT'S COMMON SENSE AND WE SHOULD
BE DOING THIS SO GREAT THAT
YOU'RE BACK HERE AGAIN I TALK
ABOUT THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
PLEASE FISHING THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION I TO WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR HIS ONGOING
LEADERSHIP -- IN TRYING TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AS WELL AS
COMMITTEE STAFF IN THE CHAIR FOR
ALL OF THEIR WORK IN AND
POSITIVE COMMENTS I'M IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL -- AS THE AUTHOR
NOTED -- THIS WOULD REALLY HELP
THE COMPLAIN INDUSTRY WE ARE
VERY MUCH A CHALLENGED UNDER THE
NEW.
REGIME THAT WAS ENACTED BY THIS
LEGISLATURE AND ALSO APPROVED AS
PART OF PROP SIXTY FOUR SO WE
ARE WORKING VERY DILIGENTLY TO
TRY TO REDUCE BARRIERS AND THIS
IS -- ONE ASPECT OR WHEN --
PROVISION THAT WILL S. GREATLY
ASSIST THE INDUSTRY -- IT
PROMOTE STATE TAX PARITY -- BY
GIVING LICENSE BUSINESSES THE
SAME OPPORTUNITIES AFFORDED.
TO SAYS AS THE AUTHOR NOTED IT
REDUCES THE TAX BURDEN ON
LICENSE CANNABIS BUSINESSES AS
WE HAVE READ IN MANY
PUBLICATIONS AND I HAVE
CONSISTENTLY MENTIONED -- WE ARE
PAYING WELL IN EXCESS OF 49% OR
GREATER IN TAXES BOTH STATE AND
LOCAL -- AND IT REALLY IS AS THE
AUTHOR NOTED REDUCES BARRIERS TO
ENTRY -- WE ARE DOING EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO ENCOURAGE COMPLIANCE
TO ENCOURAGE OPERATORS TO GET
INTO THE REGULATED MARKET PLACE
AND THIS -- WILL PROVIDE SOME
MUCH NEEDED RELIEF AND AGAIN
PARITY TWO OPERATORS THAT SHOULD
BE -- LICENSED AND ABLE TO LOOK
AT COMPLY WITH ALL THE EXISTING
TAX LOSS OF FOR ALL THESE
REASONS AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE BILL THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THINKING
WE'RE NOT GONNA WELCOME ANYONE
ELSE WOULD LIKE THERE'S BEGIN
SUPPORT FIRST LAST NAME AN
ORGANIZATION GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- WE ALSO WANTED TO
THANK THE MEMBER FOR THIS VERY
IMPORTANT MEASURE ON TRACY
STEVEN TONS.
WITH YOUR CAL CANNABIS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING SIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PLAY JOHNSON HER ABOUT
HIS TEACHERS IF YOU WANNA HEAR
AND SHALL SUPPORT.
MY SHEPHERD ON BEHALF OF THE CAL
ASIAN CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
SUPPORT.
MURPHY ON BEHALF WITH MAPS IN
THANK YOU SO MUCH THE MORNING.
MORNING ALARM THE SAUDIS ON
BEHALF OF UNITED KIND OF HIS
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE COMPLETE ADVANCE.
WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE TO TURN
TO SEE IF ANYONE IS SUPPOSED TO
BE TO PLEASE COME FORWARD.
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSED.
IT'S BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS CONVERSATIONS ARE
MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY CENTER MORE
LIKE THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
VICE CHAIR [inaudible]
HIDING.
MR JONES SAWYER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSER I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND THE CENTER
REQUIRES ONE OF THE FOUNDING
FATHERS OF CANNABIS IN STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I WANT TO THANK YOU ALSO.
I DO WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
THE THE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE -- IN IT
IS BEING EXTREMELY CHALLENGING
THIS IS THE THIRD TIME -- THAT
THIS BILL HAS ADVANCED.
IT NEEDS TO PASS IT'S ABOUT.
THE QUALITY ACROSS THE STATE IN
ITS COMMON FLIPPIN SENSE THANK
YOU SO MUCH YOU SHOULD HAVE TO
LEGISLATIVE BUT YOU ARE -- IN
GRATEFUL FOR THAT SO WE DO HAVE
A MOTION -- ON THE FLOORS IS A
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO SAN
APPROPRIATIONS MISSING
CHESTERTON PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WIRE.
MORE LIKE I BILL RIGHT NOW ALL
RIGHT HERTZBERG RICARDO
[inaudible]
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO WIENER.
WIENER I FOR ONE THAT CURRENTLY
ENJOYS A FOUR ONE VOTE IS A
MEMBER WE'RE GONNA KEEP THROW
OPEN AND WILL ADD ON THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MAKING MANY MEMBERS
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS ARE NOW MOVING ON TO A.
B. TWO ELEVEN MAJORITY LEADER
CALDERON.
WE WANT TO TAKE MOM TO SAY THANK
THE MAJORITY LEADER FOR WORKING
WITH US -- IT'S ANOTHER
COMMONSENSE BILL AND GREATLY
NEEDED WE ALSO WANT TO GO HOME
TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE.
FOR HER PARTNERSHIP AS WELL.
MR MAJORITY LEADER FLOORS YOUR
SIGNED ITEM NUMBER TWO A. B. TWO
ELEVEN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AND I WILL START BY
TAKING THE COMMITTEE MEMBER AND
SO I REALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK
VIEW IN YOUR COMMITTEE -- YOUR
THESE MEMONS I'M VERY HAPPY WITH
THEM ACTUALLY DO MADE THE BILL
BETTER OPEN UP TO MORE PEOPLE SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT -- ONE OF THE
GREATEST HURDLES THAT STUDENTS
IN THE FAMILY SPACE IN
CALIFORNIA.
IS WHEN THEY'RE CONTEMPLATING
WHETHER TO PURSUE A HIGHER
EDUCATION GIVEN THE SKYRIDE
ROCKETING COSTS OF ATTENDING
COLLEGE A FIVE TWENTY NINE PLAN
IS A FEDERALLY TAX ADVANTAGED
SAVINGS PLAN DESIGNED TO
ENCOURAGE FAMILIES TO SAVE FOR
THE FUTURE EDUCATION COSTS.
CALIFORNIA EXAMS.
COLLEGE SAVINGS ACCOUNT EARNINGS
FROM TAXES IF FUNDS ARE
WITHDRAWN.
ALL OF AYE HIGHER EDUCATION
EXPENSES BUT NO INCENTIVE IS
PROVIDED TO PROVIDE PROACTIVELY
ENCOURAGE SAVINGS IN A FIVE
TWENTY NINE ACCOUNT.
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF ONLY SEVEN
STATES WITH THE PERSONAL INCOME
TAX THAT DOES NOT OFFER A TAX
INCENTIVE FOR SAVING WITH A FIVE
TWENTY NINE PLAN.
SUPPORTING STUDENTS CALLS
JOURNEY IS THE GREATEST
INVESTMENT OUR STATE CAN MAKE
AND LIFTING PEOPLE OUT OF
POVERTY AND SUPPORTING
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC GROWTH.
THIS BILL DOES THIS BY PROVIDING
A TAX DEDUCTION FOR
CONTRIBUTIONS TO A SCHOLARSHIP
BY TWENTY NINE ACCOUNT WITH A
LIMIT OF FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
FOR SINGLE FILERS AND TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THOSE WHO
FILE JOINTLY I'M OF THE MINDSET
THAT BECAUSE WE HAVE
SKYROCKETING EDUCATION COSTS WE
DON'T WANT.
CASA COLLEGE GET TO CONTINUE TO
BE AN EMPLOYMENT FOR STUDENTS
AND AND YOUNG FOLKS TO PURSUE A
COLLEGE EDUCATION -- AND SO
BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE AN
INCENTIVE FOR SAVING IN FIVE
TWENTY NINE COUNTALLOWS US TO
HAVE ONE MORE TOOL TO HELP.
LESSEN THAT BURDEN AND I THINK
THAT IT SHOULD BE A TAX
DEDUCTION AND THERE SHOULD BE AN
INCENTIVE BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR SAVING FOR THIS
PURPOSE BECAUSE OF THE
IMPLICATIONS THAT IT MEANS. FOR
THE FUTURE OF OUR STATE SO WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE IN WITH ME TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IS KELSEY O'CONNOR
WAS DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATION FOR
THE STATE TREASURER'S.
OFFICE MYSTERY ON MOM AND STANDS
AT THOUGH WHO IS THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THIS CULTURE
INVESTMENT BOARD.
IT'S A CAR THE WHITE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS THE
COMMITTEE RAINS CASEY O'CONNOR
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR STATE
TREASURER AND CHAIR OF THE
SCHOLARS YOUR INVESTMENT BOARD
FIONA.
IS VERY CONCERNING TO OUR OFFICE
THAT STUDENT LOAN DEBT IN THE U.
S. HAS NOW TOPPED ONE POINT FIVE
TRILLION IT'S TO PASS AUTOMOBILE
AUTOMOBILE LOANS.
CREDIT CARD LOANS AS BECOME THE
LARGEST SOURCE OF PERSONAL DATA
ASIDE FROM MORTGAGES WHICH IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT MORTGAGE
DEBT HAS ONLY INCREASED THREE
POINT 2%.
WELL STUDENT LOAN DEBT HAS GROWN
102%.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST
NUMBER OF BORROWERS CONTRIBUTING
TO THIS AMOUNT WITH THREE POINT
SEVEN MILLION BORROWERS IN OUR
STATE ALONE WE HAVE SEEN THE
AVERAGE NATIONAL STUDENT LOAN
DEBTS OR 43% BETWEEN.
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND SEVEN AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHAT THE
AVERAGE CALIFORNIANS STUDENT
LOAN DEBT FROM GRADUATING CLASS
OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN AT TWENTY
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS
200-007-0080 FIVE DOLLARS PER
STUDENT.
IN ADDITION A RECENT STUDY FOUND
THAT MILLENNIALS BEAR THE BRUNT
OF THAT BURDEN WAS 75% OF THE
GENERATION.
HEARING SOME FORM OF COLLEGE
DEBT.
YET DESPITE THESE ALARMING
TRENDS ONLY 56% OF FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN UNDER THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN HAVE STARTED SAVING FOR
COLLEGE.
CURRENTLY THIRTY FOUR STATES AND
THE DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA OFFER
THE RESIDENTS OF FULL OR PARTIAL
STATE TAX DEDUCTION. FOR CREDIT
FOR CONTRIBUTIONS TO A FIVE
TWENTY NINE PLAN THE CALIFORNIA
WOULD BE ON FOR OTHER STATES IF
WE WERE TO PASS THIS MEASURE --
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT WE
SEE A DIRECT CORRELATION WITH
TAX INCENTIVES LEADING TO AN
INCREASE IN ACCOUNTS OPEN IN
OTHER STATES.
MASSACHUSETTS BEING THE MOST
RECENT EXAMPLE PASSED A
ESTABLISH ITS TAX INCENTIVE
PROGRAM IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND
HAS SEEN A 52% GROWTH IN
ACCOUNTS OPEN SENSE WE HAVE SOME
DATA CORRELATING THAT WITH.
ACCOUNTS ORE OPEN MEANS MORE
STUDENTS IN THE FUTURE GO TO
COLLEGE BALL IT STAND TAEJON
THAT.
THIS BILL PASSED OUT OF THE
ASSEMBLY WITH UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT SEVENTY EIGHT
ZERO WE SEE THIS IS COMMON SENSE
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE THANK
YOU SO MUCH MONEY SIR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO ADD ANY ITEMS.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE COMMUTING
GOVERNANCE FINANCE.
I'M STANDS IT'LL DEPUTY DIRECTOR
DISCLOSURE INVESTMENT FOR WITH
MINISTER THIS CULTURE FIVE
TWENTY NINE PROGRAM -- THE PLAN.
SERVES AS A IMPORTANT VEHICLE
FOR FAMILIES SAVING FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION -- WE'VE BEEN DOING
OVER THE LAST TWENTY YEARS WE
NOW HAVE -- NINE BILLION DOLLARS
IN ASSETS -- IN THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND ACCOUNTS
AND JUST LAST YEAR WE SAW FIVE
HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS USED -- FOR BY FAMILIES
TO PAY FOR QUALIFIED HIGHER
EDUCATION EXPENSES WITH MUCH OF
THE FUNDS USED OUT -- USE FOR
STUDENTS ATTENDING UC AND CSU
CAMPUSES -- AND THEN -- WE ALSO.
SEARCH THAT CORRELATES.
COLLEGE SAVINGS ACCOUNTS WITH
GREATER ECONOMIC [inaudible]
OPPORTUNITY -- STUDIES SHOW THAT
CHILDREN WITH A COST SAVINGS OF
LESS THAN FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
OR THREE TIMES MORE LIELY. TO
ENROLL HIGHER EDUCATION AND FOUR
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO GRADUATE
THAN THOSE WITHOUT A COLLEGE
SAVINGS ACCOUNT.
ON SO WE FEEL THAT BY OFFERING
FAMILIES WILL START TO SAVE OR
SAVE MORE. FOR THEIR FUTURE
HIGHER SHAKE EDUCATION EXPENSES
IN STATES BY TWENTY PLAN WILL
BENEFITING.
FROM THE TAX ADVANTAGE THE PLAN
OFFERS.
ANY AMOUNT SAVED WOULD BE LESS
FAMILIES WE NEED TO TAKE OUT AND
IN STUDENT LOANS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY WERE VERY GRATEFUL
WE'RE GONNA OPEN UP FOR ANYONE
ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE THIS BECAUSE
PART FOR SOME LASSEN
ORGANIZATION GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING RIVER NOW DIRECTOR
OF EDUCATION FOR THE CATHOLIC
CHURCH IN CALIFORNIA WHEN STRONG
SUPPORT COULD YOU SEE RAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING SIR.
GOOD MORNING DAVID O'BRIEN TO
CALIFORNIA'S TO NAY COMMISSION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WOULD LIKE TO BE A LOOK AT A
LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT.
NOW I WOULD LIKE TO BE A LOOK AT
THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED TO
COMPLETE ADVANCE TO THE TABLE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING WELCOME BACK.
GOOD MORNING JENNIFER BAKER WITH
THE TEACHERS AT CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE I DO
WANT -- TO PROVIDE CLARITY WITH
THE NINETEEN PLANTS ARE A AN
EXTREMELY EFFECTIVE TOOL. TO
HELP PARENTS TO SAVE FOR THEIR
CHILDREN TO BE ABLE TO ATTEND
COLLEGE THE DILEMMA THAT WE HAVE
IS WERE CREATING SOMETHING ON
TOP OF A SYSTEM -- THAT WOULD
ULTIMATELY IMPACT GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS A NIGHT MY AGAIN WANT TO
REMIND THE COMMITTEE 40% OFF A
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS THAT ARE
IMPACTED WHAT IMPACT PROP NINETY
EIGHT IN OUR SCHOOLS WHICH ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY K. TWELVE SO
IN A SENSE.
MUCH OF THE FUNDING THAT'S ALSO
BEING PROVIDED FOR THIS BILL.
WOULD ALSO MEAN THAT K. TWELVE
SCHOOLS ARE NOT GOING TO HAVE AS
MUCH OVERALL FINDINGS WE JUST
WANT TO ENCOURAGE -- THE
LEGISLATURE IN THIS COMMITTEE TO
THINK ABOUT AS YOU'RE GOING TO
EXPAND PROGRAMS TO MAYBE LOOK AT
THE EXISTING PROGRAMS THAT WE
HAVE IN MAY BE RE CALIBRATE
PRIORITIES.
HIGHER TO ADDING THINGS ON TOP
BECAUSE THAT WILL THEN MAKE IT
EASIER FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO BE
ABLE TO PRIORITIZE OVERALL TO
SAY ARE THE EXISTING DEDUCTIONS
ARE THE EXISTING TAX CREDITS.
ARE THE EXISTING ECONOMIC
INCENTIVES THAT YOU'RE PROVIDING
AS A STATE OR THEY CONSISTENT
WITH YOUR CURRENT VALUES -- AND
WE THINK IF YOU DO THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO BE IN A BETTER POSITION
TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT MEASURES
LIKE THIS SHOULD YOU DO THAT IT
WOULD MAKE IT EASIER.
IT WOULD MAKE IT EASIER FOR US
TO BE IN A POSITION IN THE
FUTURE TO NOT.
HI BILLS THAT ARE VERY GOOD
IDEAS WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
AT THE END OF THE DAY OUR
STUDENTS AND OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AREN'T GOING TO BE SUBSIDIZING
THEM [inaudible]
WHICH I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME
ANYONE ELSE GOOD MORNING THE
MORNING DOWNLOAD THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION WHO
WE WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH THE SCTA.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANK YOU SO
MUCH THE MORNING HIM.
GOOD MORNING JOANNE BUT IN COURT
REPRESENTING THE SECURITIES
INDUSTRY AND FINANCIAL MARKETS
ASSOCIATION ARE SAFE BUT WE ARE
ACTUALLY REMOVING.
OUR OPPOSITION.
WE NOW HAVE A SUPPORT IF AMENDED
POSITION.
WEEK AGREED A 100% WITH THE
INTENT OF THE BILL.
WE JUST FEEL THAT THE TAX
DEDUCTION SHOULD APPLY TO ALL
FIVE TWENTY NINE PLANS TO GET
CALIFORNIANS MORE CHOICE THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION IF YOU
COULD PLEASE ADVANCE THIS TIME.
LAST CALL.
I WOULD LIKE TO BETTER BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE I'LL HAVE A
VERY QUICK CLOSING COMMENT
ELECTED.
CENTER WHAT FOR SURE SIR THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR OF THIS -- I
JUST WANNA CLARIFYA COUPLE
THINGS WHEN WE'RE GIVING A
DEDUCTION UP FRONT WHICH THE
FEDERAL CODE.
DOES NOT.
SO WERE NONCONFORMITY.
SO OVER GIVING A DEDUCTION FRONT
EVERY.
GOING TO MAKE A TAXABLE WHEN IT
IS PULLED.
NO -- WE WOULDN'T CHANGE THAT WE
WOULDN'T IT RIGHT NOW ALREADY AS
IT IS WITH A FIVE FIVE TWENTY
NINE CULTURE ACCOUNT.
YOU DON'T GET TAXED IN AS LONG
AS YOU'RE PULLING IT OUT FOR
SPECIFIC EDUCATION PURPOSES AS
LONG AS IT'S BEEN PULLED OUT FOR
SPECIFIC EDUCATION PURPOSES
YOU'RE NOT GONNA BE.
TAX ON A BRIGHT RED.
THIS IS SORT OF LIKE AN IRA
YOU'RE GETTING A DEDUCTION UP
FRONT SO WHEN YOU PULL THE MONEY
OUT OF AN IRA YOU'RE TAXED ON ON
THE WAY OUT.
AND SO YOU'RE SAYING.
WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA HAVE.
A TURBO CHARGED THE FEDERAL CODE
GIVE A DEDUCTION GOING IN AND
NOT.
MAKING IT INCOME.
WHEN IT COMES OUT OF THAT TRUST
CURRENTLY YOU JUST DON'T HAVE TO
BE TAXED ON WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
THAT?
TRUSTED IS SORT OF A LIKE A
ESCROW ACCOUNT.
BUT I MEAN I HAVE BRING IN --
JOINT.
FANS ARE SORRY STAND DOT -- TALK
A BIT MORE ABOUT THAT BUT I MEAN
THIS IS SOMEONE DOING A STATE
LEVEL WE'RE NOT IMPACTING
OVERDUE I FEDERAL BUT MAYBE YOU
CAN.
ARGUE ABOUT THE STANDING ON THE
FEDERAL LEVEL BUT NO I
UNDERSTAND BUT WE'RE WE'RE
PROVIDING A STATE DEDUCTION.
BRIDGES AND IT AND SO I I WANT
TO FLESH OUT THIS ARGUMENT
THAT'S BEING MADE IRONICALLY BY
TEACHER REPRESENTATIVE.
ON EDUCATION BUT BUT IT'S A
BALLOT ARGUMENT AND SO.
YOU HAVE THIRTY FOUR OTHER
STATES THAT ARE DOING THIS AND
THEY'RE ALLOWING A DEDUCTION.
UP FRONT JUST ON THE STATE WOULD
TURN OUT THE FEDERAL BUT JIM ON
THE STATE'S AS NONCONFORMING.
BUT THEY DON'T REFLECTED AS
INCOME WHEN IT'S PULLED OUT OF
ITS USE.
FOR EDUCATION PURPOSES.
IN BFORE YET AGAIN HAVE YOU
INTRODUCE YOURSELF OR TIME BUT I
THINK THE OTHER PIECE I'D LIKE
TO BE A MENTION AS IN A WAY TO
THE END IS THAT.
THANK ON THE THE BIG PICTURE ON
THE ISSUE TAX CREDITS TO THIS
COMMITTEE REMEMBERS RIGHT.
AT ISSUE TAX CREDITS WHICH IS
THE BIGGEST IMPACT ON THE
GENERAL FUND THIS COMMITTEE PASS
AND A SIX YEAR VOTE TO BE ABLE
TO ADVANCE SENATOR JACKSONVILLE.
TO BE ABLE TO STUDY THAT -- SO I
THINK THAT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE THAT WE NEED TO BE TO
BRING IN I UNDERSTAND IT'S A BIT
APPLES AND ORANGES.
BUT ARE THERE SOME BALLOT
ARGUMENTS OR BROAD FOR THIS
COMMITTEE TOOK ACTION ON THAT TO
BE ABLE TO STUDY -- PENDING
APPROVAL BY THE ASSEMBLY NOVICE
WHO THE GOVERNOR.
AND TURN IT BACK OVER TO YOU SIR --
IF YOU MIGHT REINTRODUCE
YOURSELF.
IS UNDERSTAND ZERO W. THE
DIRECTOR OF THIS CULTURE MESSAGE
BOARD SO IF I TWENTY NINE
PROGRAMS -- YOU KNOW.
THE CONTRIBUTIONS GO TO THE
COUNT POST TAX SO ON FOLKS ARE
PAYING TAXES ON IT -- NOW THIS
DEDUCTION WOULD -- WOULD ALLOW
THEM TO DEDUCT FROM THEIR INCOME
ALL THE EARNINGS THAT ARE
ACCUMULATED IN THE ACCOUNT ARE
TAX FREE FEDERAL AND STATE LEVEL --
INTERVIEWS RECALL [inaudible]
EXPENSES -- AND THIS THIS BILL
OUTLINES A DOCTOR DUCKS IN A LOT
OF THIS THE PROGRAM SOME OF THEM
HAVE TAX CREDITS MAJORITY OF
THEM HAVE TAX DEDUCTIONS -- I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT ANSWERS YOUR
QUESTION BUT NO JUST BRINGS TO
THE POINT OF THIS THIRTY FOUR
STATES TO BE DO ANY OF ANY OF
THEM HAVE ANYTHING SIMILAR TO
PROP -- NINETY EIGHT IT WOULD
HAVE TO LOOK INTO THAT WHAT'S A
PRETTY UNIQUE ANIMAL.
PROP NINE YEAH YEAH SO WE'VE GOT
A DIFFERENT BIRD HERE SO HOW DO
WE HOW DO WE RESOLVE THAT.
OR WE DON'T WE JUST WERE MAKING
A CHOICE [inaudible]
AND YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN THAT
YOU LOOK I CAN GET BACK TO WITH
A BETTER ANSWER -- IF YOU NEED
IT AND AND AND I THINK.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IS PROVIDE AN INCENTIVE.
THAT WE CAN PROVIDE ON THE STATE
LEVEL. TO HELP ENCOURAGE SAVINGS.
IN THESE FIVE TWENTY NINE
ACCOUNTS BECAUSE IT'S BEEN
UTILIZED IN OTHER STATES NOW I I
CAN GO BACK AND I CAN LOOK TO
SEE WHAT THE IMPACT IS WHEN IT
YOU KNOW FEDERAL YOU KNOW WHEN
TAX SEASON COMES AROUND. TO SEE
IF THAT IMPACT IF THIS WILL
IMPACT THAT MINUS AS IT AND THAT
IS THAT IT WON'T BUT I CAN.
I CAN LOOK INTO THAT WAS SOON
CALLED RUN I'M.
VERY ENVIOUS THAT THIS
OPPORTUNITY IS AVAILABLE FOR YOU.
IT WAS NOT FOR ME -- WHEN I WAS
PUTTING MONEY ASIDE FOR MY KIDS
COLLEGE EDUCATION SO IT'S IT'S
GREAT?
WONDERFUL I'M JUST TRYING.
TO FIGURE OUT HOW IT ALL
BALANCES OUT BECAUSE IS THE
CHAIR SAID YOU KNOW ALL THESE
CREDITS AND INCENTIVES.
THAT THERE'S THE WE HAVE A WE
HAVE.
AN UNRESTRICTED NET DEFICIT OF
TWO HUNDRED THIRTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS THAT WE GOT TO ATTACK.
SO I'M TRYING TO BALANCE.
THOSE THOSE ISSUES SO THANK YOU
FOR EARLY UNDERSTAND.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER VICE CHAIR
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF WE NEED TO
TIONAL COMMENTS QUESTIONS
CONVERSATION FROM THE TWENTY AT
THIS TIME.
HEARING TEEN ANSWER MOTION TO BE
ABLE TO ADVANCE A.
TWO ELEVEN WE HAVE A MOTION BY
CENTER TARA SURGERY LEVY LIKE
CLOSER THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND QUESTIONS SENATORS RESPECT
LAST WHEN I VOTE THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER YOUR LEADER WE ALSO
WANT TO SAY THANKS TO THOSE THAT
FROM THE TREASURER'S OFFICE --
FOR ALL THEIR WORK ONCE IT THINK
THOUGH IT TO THOSE WHO MAY BE
POSTED THIS TIME AS WELL ALWAYS
GRATEFUL YOU'RE IN COMMITTEE
THIS IS A DO PASSES THE MANAGERS
AND APPROPRIATIONS MISSING
CHESTER ROLL CALL PLEASE WIRE I
WHY I AM MORE A LOT.
BELLE.
BELLE ISLE HERTZBERG FURTADO.
I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE YEAH.
FIVE THE CURRENT ENJOYS A FIVE
ZERO VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP IT
WILL OPEN IN.
FOLKS COMING THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THEY GENERALLY COMMITTEE WOULD
NOW LIKE TO MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER FOUR THIS IS AB.
THREE TWO ONE MISTER PATTERSON
WE WELCOME IS A PATTERSON TO
COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WE HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THE BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU. FIVE INSTRUCTION WAS
YOUR FIRST IT WILL MAKE IT.
YEAH AND MAKE A QUICK THANK YOU
SO MUCH SIR AND WE'RE GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR WORK -- WELL VERY
QUICKLY -- AND I'M HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS
WITH RESPECT TO THE LA -- REPORT --
THERE WAS INCLUDED -- BUT UP
CURRENTLY COMMERCIAL TRUCKS ARE
TREATED DIFFERENTLY.
THAN COMMERCIAL BOB TRAILERS.
THE MAN WHICH WE TREAT
COMMERCIAL TRUCKS AS A
DISINCENTIVE TO BUY.
IN CALIFORNIA BUT WE DON'T HAVE
THOSE SAME REQUIREMENTS ON A
COMMERCIAL TRAILERS WHAT THE
BILL DOES IS.
IT BRINGS INTO PARITY THE LAW
REGARDING TAXATION FOR
COMMERCIAL TRUCKS AND TRAILERS
USED IN INTERSTATE -- COMMERCE
UP VERY VERY SIMPLY -- BY
REMOVING THE REQUIREMENT THAT
COMMERCIAL VEHICLES MUST BE
BROUGHT INTO THE STATE AFTER THE
PURCHASE.
SB THREE TWENTY ONE HELPS REDUCE
EMISSIONS.
OF WEAR AND TEAR ON OUR ROADS.
BUYERS AND DEALERS TIME WHEN
PURCHASING OR SELLING
COMMERCIALS -- COMMERCIAL
VEHICLES CALIFORNIA PLUS IT THE
MOVES CALIFORNIA TO A MUCH MORE
COMPETITIVE -- POSITION FOR UP.
THE PURCHASE OF OF A THE TRUCKS
AND TRAILERS.
IN CALIFORNIA UP.
WITH THAT I WANT -- TO TURN HERE
TO WIDELY HOWARD WITH CALIFORNIA
TRUCK CENTERS AND WE DO HAVE A
SUPPORT.
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH
ASSEMBLY IN IS.
QUICKLY.
GOT HIRED FOR SURE SIR GERMAN --
YEAH I'VE REPRESENT -- THE
LARGEST TRUCK DEALERSHIP IN
CALIFORNIA WE'VE GOT SEVEN
ROOFTOPS WORRY ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND TRUCKS.
A YEAR THAT WE SELL THE GOING TO
INTERSTATE COMMERCE -- WE ARE
WE'VE BUSINESS TO BUSINESS AND
SO SOME CUSTOMERS PURCHASE
MULTIPLE TRUCKS AND WE HAVE TO
DELIVER WHAT TRUCKS ONE AT A
TIME OUT OF STATE -- TO TAKE
POSSESSION OF THE OF OF THAT
TRACK -- WE'RE NOT HAULING A
LOAD THE PICKING UP A TRAILER AT
THE DEALERSHIP THAT'S NOT
REQUIRED TO THE OUT OF STATE --
HOLIDAY AT THE LOAD UPWARDS OF
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY MILES WHICH
USES BURNS ON WANTED FUEL -- AND
IT JUST BECOMES A BURDEN ON THE
CUSTOMER ME WHERE AN EXPORT AG
EXPORTS STATE YET WE CAN.
WHAT ARE THE CALIFORNIA SO THE
TRUCK CALLS MOVES BURNED UP TO
FIFTY GALLONS OF FUEL WITHOUT
EVEN?
MOVING ANY GOODS -- FOR THE MORE
JUST ONE MORE POINT IS THAT --
WHEN WE AS DEALERSHIP SET UP A
DELIVERY WE WE SHOULD PUT OUT
THIRTY FIVE GALLONS IN THE TRUCK --
THAT'S PURCHASED IN CALIFORNIA.
THE CUSTOMER THEN TRAVELS.
TO ARIZONA NEVADA AND WE'LL TALK
THE TRUCK OFF IT'S A TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY GALLONS IN NEVADA AND
THEN GO ON TO GO PICK UP A LOAD
OF WE CAN HAND THE KEYS TO THEM
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THEN.
THEY'RE GONNA PUT TWENTY GALLONS
OF FUEL IN THE TRUCK IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WITH.
DIESEL TAX AND EVERYTHING THAT
DEFINITELY HELPS WITH
INFRASTRUCTURE SO.
I RESPECTIVELY -- ASK FOR AN EYE
ON THIS AND EVERY COMPANY
QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE ANY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE DO HAVE
MOTION ON THE FLOOR THANKS SO
MUCH CENTER TITLE WE WELCOME MR
FIRST LASSEN ORGANIZATION --
MERRIMENT COMPANY TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION HERE IN SUPPORT AS
WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH GRATEFUL
YOU'RE HERE WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
OF PLEASE COME FOR THIS TIME.
NOW LIKE TURN OVER THOSE WHO MAY
BE OPPOSED PLEASE ADVANCED
LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO OPPOSED.
LAST CALL.
WILL BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
THIS BILL SIMPLY TRYING TO BRING
PARITY TO LAW LIKE TODAY TO SEE
IF WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
MR BY SHARE THE CLARIFICATION
GESTURE OF THIS SALES TAX AT
REDUCING IS IT JUST.
THE STATE'S PORTION OR IS IT
ALSO THE CITY'S [inaudible] 1%
[inaudible]
SUMMER.
BUT WHAT WE'RE DOING A PARITY
WITH THAT WITH THE TRAILER SO
WHAT IT WAS ONE OF WHATEVER THE
TRAILER TAX.
IT CAN BE BOTH.
BUT TO BE IDENTICAL SO ABOUT AND
SO WHAT WHAT CITY ARE YOU
LOCATED MISTER HOWARD FRESNO
PRESIDENT PRESIDENT HAS NOT
OPPOSING THIS BILL [inaudible]
NOW.
THANK YOU INTERSTATE COMMERCE
VEHICLES -- ARE UNDER FEDERAL
TRADE SO THEY FALL UNDER
DIFFERENT JURISDICTION FOR SALES
TAX.
AND WHEN WE TALK TO THE THE
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION THE THERE WILL BE
SOME SMALL LOSS THEY
CHARACTERIZE THEIR WORD IS
MINIMAL -- ACROSS THE STATE.
I DON'T THINK SO MUCH MISTER
VICE CHAIR [inaudible]
WE'RE GRATEFUL.
ALL RIGHTS IN THERE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO BE A CLOSE APPRECIATED
THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT AND ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH WE DO HAVE A MOTION
ON THE FLOOR BY CENTER TYLER
THIS IS A DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
PREPARATIONS.
AS I JUST ROLL CALL PLEASE WIDER
HI WHY I'M MORE A LOT.
MORE LIKE AYE BELL.
I HERTZBERG RICARDO.
YOUR TOTAL AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
SIX IS A SIX ZERO VOTE MISTER
SUMMER THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK
SIR IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU THANK
YOU.
GOOD JOB.
THEY GENERALLY WERE NOW BRINGING
UP THE MANAGEMENT ELECTION FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THIS IS ITEM
NUMBER THREE ENERGY INTO THIS IS
AB THREE OH EIGHT SUMMER
MURATSUCHI WE WALKED ME SIR.
THEY WERE TO GO -- TO SOME NEVER
STONE.
RIGHT AFTER THAT THIS MURATSUCHI
THE FLOOR IS YOURS WE WELCOME
YOU IN THIS RESEARCH YOU DO HAVE.
A BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON YOUR
BILL YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN SENATORS I AM
PRESENTING ASSEMBLY BILL.
THREE ZERO EIGHT WHICH IS A
MODEST BUT IMPORTANT BILL TO
PROVIDE A TAX BREAK FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES.
SOLELY OWNED BY DEPLOYED
SOLDIERS OF THE UNITED STATES
ARMED FORCES.
HOW CAN ANYONE NOT SUPPORT THIS
BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
IPHONE?
WE DO HAVE A MOTION BY CENTER
DATO HI DATING MISS MURATSUCHI
HEY THERE YOU GO.
WE'LL TURN IT OVER THOSE WHO MAY
BE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
WELCOME THANK YOU AND GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
GREG HAYES HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES.
TOUGH TO TOP THAT OPENING BUT
JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT THERE ARE
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND VETERAN OWNED
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA.
WHEN THOSE -- SERVICE MEMBERS
ARE DEPLOYED OVERSEAS THE SEEMS
TO BE A RELATIVELY MINOR --
BENEFIT TO THEM WE WANT TO
MAINTAIN THAT DISTINCTION OF
HAVING THE MOST VETERAN OWNED
BUSINESSES IN THE U. S..
SO -- WE HOPE FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH AS
REYES WERE NOW ELECT MEADOW
OPENING UP TO ANYONE ELSE WHO
MAYBE WANT TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
PERSON LAST ORGANIZATION LASKAR
FLOWS IN SPORT.
NOW LIKELY TO SEE IF THERE IS
ANYONE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED TO
PLEASE COME FORWARD THIS TIME.
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSE WILL BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE WE DO HAVE
A MOTION THE FLOOR BY CENTER
TITLE SO BY SHARE THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF JUST A
CLARIFICATION YES -- SO -- THE
OWNER IS OVERSEAS.
BUT MAYBE HAS A MANAGER RUNNING
THE BUSINESS.
AND IT'S GENERATING A PROFIT.
AND IT HAS.
REVENUES IN THAT THAT -- TAXABLE
IN EXCESS OF THE MINIMUM TAX.
ARE WE ARE WE ELIMINATING THE
EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS.
NO THE AS THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
INDICATES THERE THERE TO
QUALIFICATIONS THE THE OWNERS
DEPLOYED AND THE CORPORATION
OPERATES AT A LOSS OR CEASES
OPERATION IN THAT TAX.
THAT'S THE CLARIFICATION I
NEEDED THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU MISTER THANK YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIR.
BUT I COULD SEE THERE'S ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONVERSATION FROM ONE COMMITTEE.
KERN SCENE AND WE DO HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY CENTER
KIND OF THIS IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE BUT AT
VETERANS AFFAIRS.
THIS MESSAGE YOU'D LIKE TO GET
CLOSER I ASKED WE AYE VOTE THIS
CENTER CIRCLE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WIRED HIGH WIRE I'M MORE A
LOT.
MORE LIKE I BILL.
THEY'LL AYE HERTZBERG FURTADO.
THE TOTAL I'D NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER.
WE ARE I THINK SO THE CURRENT
ENJOYS A SIX ZERO VOTE GOOD TO
SEE SIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN.
PLEASE IN GERMAN COMING STRAIGHT
FROM GOOD CITY SANTA CRUZ WE ARE
BRINGING UP MISTER MARK STONE
SUMMER MARK STONE WHO'S HERE TO
BE A PRESENT.
AB.
FOUR ONE ONE HE'S GONNA GIVE US
ALL THE INFO.
IF THAT HER TITLE FOUR ONE ONE
INFO THANK YOU -- BE HERE ALL
NIGHT -- IT SIMMERS SO THE FLOOR
IS YOURS HE LOOKS FOR FREE.
THANK YOU YOU HAD A REAL STRING
OF BIPARTISAN BILLS I'M SO MEAN
THIS IS SUPPORT SUPPORT AS WELL.
HOUSE MR MORE LIKE IT'S
OTHERWISE ENGAGE WITH THANK YOU
THERE YEAH AB FOR ELEVEN
ADDRESSES THE SUCCESSOR AGENCY
IN THE CITY OF SANTA CRUZ WHEN
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY WAS WOUND
UP.
THE SANTA CRUZ DID EVERYTHING
THAT THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO DO
ACCORDING TO LAW.
BUT THERE REMAINS A BOND
OUTSTANDING OF ABOUT SIXTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN OUR DESIRE TO
GET AFFORDABLE HOUSING BILLS
BILLS WAT THIS BILL WOULD DO
SIMPLY ALLOW.
THE SANTA CRUZ TO USE THOSE.
INSTEAD OF SITTING IN THE
SUCCESSOR AGENCY AND THEN USE
THE PROCEEDS TO PAY OFF THE DEBT
IS TO PUT THEM TO WORK
IMMEDIATELY CITY SANTA CRUZ HAS
A NUMBER OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS READY TO GO RIGHT NOW.
AND WOULD BE ABLE TO USE THIS
MONEY FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
PHIL IT'S CRITICAL NEED IN THE
CITY OF SANTA CRUZ WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE I
DO HAVE SOME.
PEOPLE FROM THE CITY OF SANTA
CRUZ MONEY LIPS COME WHO WAS A
FORMER MANAGER OF THE
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY WHEN IT
EXISTED THAT WAS CITY STAFF
WORKING IN THE PLANNING.
AND DEVELOPMENT AREA AND CAN
ATTEST TO WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
AND SEE SANTA CRUZ.
I ASK FOR YOUR IBM THANK YOU SO
MUCH REMEMBER GOOD MORNING MA'AM
WELCOME AT THE FLOOR SHORTAGE OF
TWO MINUTES.
GREAT A GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
CHOIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE A MY NAME IS BONNIE
LIPS COME -- DIRECTOR OF
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND HOUSING
FOR THE CITY OF SANTA CRUZ AND
WITH ME TODAY ARE JO HALL
SPECIAL PROJECT MANAGER AND JUST
GO DO IT OUR HOUSING MANAGER FOR
THE CITY -- I'D OF BEFORE COMING
FOR THEIR I'D LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE -- OUR
COMMUNITIES ASSEMBLY
REPRESENTATIVE FOR INTRODUCING
THIS MEASURE -- MY BRIEF
COMMENTS WILL TRY TO CONVEY SOME
OF THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CHALLENGES FACED BY OUR
COMMUNITY OUR PAST EFFORTS IN
THE AREA OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND HOW WE CAN MOVE FORWARD
QUICKLY IF A BEFORE LET.
FOLLOWING THE EIGHTY NINE LOMA
PRIETA EARTHQUAKE THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED SPECIAL
LEGISLATION WHICH WOULD ALLOW
THE CITY OF SANTA CRUZ CREWS TO
MERGE ITS EARLIER REDEVELOPMENT
AREAS AND I'LL ALLOW US TO FOCUS
ON REBUILDING HOUSING IN OUR
COMMUNITY. ONE OF THE KEY
POLICIES THE CITY ADAPTED
FOLLOWING ADOPTED FOLLOWING THE
EARTHQUAKE WAS A HOUSING FOR
STRATEGY.
SINCE RETAILERS AND OTHER
COMMERCIAL USES ARE RELUCTANT TO
RETURN TO MARKETS DEVASTATED BY
NATURAL DISASTER SANTA CRUZ
INSTEAD CONCENTRATED ON
REPLACING ITS HOUSING FIRST WITH
THE FUNDING PROVIDED TO
REDEVELOPMENT SANTA CRUZ WAS
ABLE TO DEVELOP OVER.
THIRTEEN HUNDRED UNITS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BOTH WORK
FORCE IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
OUR COMMUNITY.
UNFORTUNATELY THE DISSOLUTION OF
THE CITY'S REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY
IN TWENTY TWELVE HAS GREATLY
IMPACTED OUR CITY'S ABILITY TO
CREATE NEW AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNITS IN OUR COMMUNITY SINCE
THAT TIME.
SINCE THEN SANTA CRUZ HAS BEEN
CITED S ONE OF THE LEAST
AFFORDABLE HOUSING MARKETS IN
THE NATION ARE GROWING UC CAMPUS
IN NEARBY SILICON VALLEY HAVE
BOTH INCREASE THE AFFORDABLE
PRESSURE.
OF LOCAL HOUSING IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
WHAT IS ALSO UNIQUE ABOUT OUR
CITY IS THAT WE STILL HAVE-AVAILABLE STAFF TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WITH THE
FUNDS PROVIDED THROUGH A BEFORE
ELEVEN WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
PROJECTS LINED UP IN OUR
DOWNTOWN CORE?
AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH OUR
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICT ON A OF OF
THE WORK FORCE.
ACT IN OUR COMMUNITY SHOULD AB
FOR ELEVEN BE APPROVED WE ALSO
HAVE A DOWNTOWN PROJECT WITH A
HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS WITH
OUR METRO TRANSIT CENTER.
AND A HEALTH CARE AND LOW COST
HEALTH CARE AND DENTAL CARE FOR
A COMMUNITIES THROUGH THE SANTA
CRUZ COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTER.
DISADVANTAGED YOUTH AND FAMILIES.
WHAT WE HOPE FOR MAYBE FOUR
ELEVEN IS AT THE FUNDING RELEASE
BY APPROVAL THIS LEGISLATION
WILL ALLOW US TO MOVE FORWARD ON
THESE PROJECTS THIRTY SECONDS?
THROUGH THESE PROJECTS WILL BE
ABLE TO MEET OUR REGIONAL
HOUSING NEEDS ALLOCATION AND
CONTINUE PROVIDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN OUR COMMUNITY AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY AND I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT A BEFORE ELEVEN AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU HAVE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU TO MAKE THE TREK
TO SEGMENT ALONG WITH THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF SANTA CHRISTINE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE.
GIVEN I WOULD LIKE TO READ A
WELCOME ANYONE ELSE FROM AND
CITY SANTA CRUZ END OR THOSE WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT MR DONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN KEITH
DONE HERE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WOULD LIKE THERE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
OF PLEASE COME FORWARD.
LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT.
NOW LIKELY TO WELCOME ANYONE WHO
MAYBE POST PLEASE COMPORTS GOOD
TO SEE YOU WELCOME BACK.
SB NATION WE DO APOLOGIZE FOR
LATE OPPOSITION WE WEREN'T ABLE
TO PROCESS -- A POSITION ON THIS
UNTIL RECENTLY AND I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHORS OFFICE FOR
BEING VERY UNDERSTANDING AND
ACCOMMODATING AS WE WERE
COMMUNICATING ON THE ISSUES --
OUR OPPOSITION TO THIS -- IS THE
SAME PHILOSOPHICAL OPPOSITION
THAT WE HAD MISTER CHAIR TO THE
MEASURE THAT BOTH YOU AND CENTER
BILL WE'RE WORKING ON SB -- FIVE
AND I KNOW WE HAVE DIFFERENT
APPROACHES TO HOW WE'RE DOING
TRYING TO DEAL WITH THE ISSUE WE
ABSOLUTELY DON'T OPPOSE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE THINK IT'S
ABSOLUTELY NEEDED.
THE DIFFICULT POSITION THAT WERE
PUT IN IN THE EDUCATION
COMMUNITY IS MANY OF THE
STRUCTURAL MECHANISMS THAT ARE
BEING PUT FORWARD ON MEASURES
SUCH AS THIS -- DO HAVE AN
IMPACT ON SCHOOL PROPERTY TAXES
AND WHILE AND THERE ARE --
ATTEMPTS TO TRY TO MITIGATE ANY
POTENTIAL NEGATIVE FISCAL
IMPACTS BY GENERAL BY BACK
FEELING FROM THE GENERAL FUND
SHOULD WE GO INTO ANOTHER
DECLINE AS WE DID IN THIS PAST
RECESSION.
AND WE'RE PUTTING HIM IN A
POSITION WHERE PROP NINETY EIGHT
MAY BE SUSPENDED AGAIN OR THE
STATE MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO BACK
FILL FROM THE GENERAL FUND.
THAT ACTUALLY PUTS THOSE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT WOULD BE IMPACTED
AT A COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE
BECAUSE THE PROPERTY TAX
REVENUES THAT THEY WOULD RECEIVE.
STABLE SOURCE OF REVENUE IN A
DOWN ECONOMIC TIME SO WHILE THE
ATTEMPT IS TO TRY TO ENSURE THAT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS -- IS --
OFFERED FOR THE CITY OF SANTA
CRUZ WHICH WE THINK IS
ABSOLUTELY ADMIRABLE AND WE'RE
CERTAINLY NOT AGAINST ANY OF
THOSE ATTEMPTS WE SIMPLY WANT TO
MAKE SURE AT THE END OF THE DAY
IF WE GOING INTO A NAKED AND
ECONOMIC ON AN ECONOMIC DECLINE.
THAT OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS -- IN
THOSE AREAS ARE ON INTENTIONALLY
IMPACTED IN A NEGATIVE WAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
PROTEST MONEY NOW THEY TO
WELCOME ANYONE ELSE WHO MAY BE
IN OPPOSITION IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COME FORTH THIS TIME
[inaudible]
THAT'S CALL.
LIKE TURN BACK TO COMMITTEE NOW
AND TURN OVER VICE CHAIR
THRESHER MORNING RESEARCHER FOR
ALLOWING ME TO ASK ONE QUESTION
FOR REBEL I APPRECIATE THAT.
HEY YOU'RE GOOD YOU'RE GOOD --
FOR CATION BECAUSE I'M.
I COME FROM PUBLIC FINANCE AND
WHEN YOU TO FEES A BOND IT'S
IT'S LIKE SETTING UP AN ORTEZ
CURRY PUT BONDS IN TO PAY OFF
THE BONTA -- TO SO.
IT WASN'T CLEAR TO ME WHAT WHAT.
WHAT WHAT THE FINANCIAL
STRUCTURE OF THIS DEFEATS AND
SAYS?
SO I'M ASSUMING EUROPE'S SIXTY
MILLION AND BY PROCEEDS THAT
WERE INVESTED SOMEWHERE TO PAY
OFF.
ANOTHER [inaudible]
BOND REQUIRE.
SO THAT'S SORT OF LIKE IN AN
ESCROW AND AND YOU'RE TRYING TO
PULL THAT MONEY OUT. TO USE IT
FOR A GOOD CAUSE BUT YOU'RE BUT
YOU'RE PULLING IT OUT.
WHICH MEANS YOU'RE NOT IN YOUR
HEAD SO I'M ASSUMING SO FAR I'M
I'M OKAY.
BUT THEN HOW DO YOU PAY FOR THE
ORIGINAL BOND.
WE'VE WE'VE BEEN ACTUALLY PAYING
FOR WE AN ORIGINAL ISSUANCES
ABOUT THIRTY FIVE MILLION AND
THROUGH REDEVELOPMENT FILE OF
THE PROCESS DISSOLUTION PROCESS
WE DID THE LAST AND FINAL -- AND
HAD A FINDING OF COMPLETION AND
SO WE HAVE BUILT INTO OUR LAST
AND FINAL -- RECOGNIZE
OBLIGATION PAYMENT SCHEDULE THE
REMAINING DEBT SERVICE PAYMENTS
WE NEED FOR THE BOND SO THIS IS
WHAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE -- IT'S
FOR THE CITY THAT WE WOULD BE
PUTTING THROUGH TO THE PASS
THROUGH ENTITIES WHICH INCLUDE
THE CITY AND THE SCHOOL DISTRICT.
THIS IS MONEY THAT'S ABOVE AND
BEYOND WHAT'S NEEDED IN A TO
FEES AND SO WE WOULD CONTENT
BRIGHT WE WE CONTINUE TO MAKE
THE DEBT SERVICE PAYMENTS AS
THEY ARE ANTICIPATED THROUGHOUT
THE LIFE OF THE OF THE BONDS
THAT OUT OF YOUR GENERAL FUND.
OUT OF THE REDEVELOPMENT -- TACK
TAX INCREMENT THAT WOULD BE
COMING THROUGH.
OUR BY APOLOGIZE ASSUMING STONE
I'D I'D SAY THEY DON'T HAVE ALL
THE NUMBERS AND YEAH BUT MAYBE A
VISUAL PERSON BUT SO SO WE HAVE
WE HAVE A THIRTY IN.
BUT YOU'VE GOT LIKE. FIFTY ONE
MILLION.
NO THIRTY FIVE THERE IT THE
ORIGINAL ISSUANCE WAS THIRTY
FIVE MILLION AND THE SIXTEEN
MILLION IS WHAT'S LEFT AFTER WE
HAVE SCHEDULED OUT THE REMAINING
DEBT SERVICE PAYMENTS SO WE WE
CONTINUE TO USE.
THE DEBT SERVICE -- THE PAYMENTS
THAT ARE SCHEDULED THROUGH OUR
ROB TO RECOGNIZE ALL THE GAME
PAYMENT SCHEDULE TO CONTINUE TO
PAY THOSE IT'S THE BALANCE OF
THAT THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE.
FOR DID THE FEES IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THAT WE BOTH HOLD
ONTO TO REINVEST INTO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
IN WHITE IS THE STATE LAW ALLOW
YOU TO HAVE THAT MONEY.
ALREADY IT'S PART OF THE
REDEVELOPMENT LAW IS THAT
DEPENDING ON WHEN YOU WHAT TIME
YOU ISSUE THE BONDS YOU ARE
AVAILABLE ELIGIBLE TO SPEND A
PERCENTAGE OF IT AND THE REST
HAS TO BE DO FEES -- TO THE
TAXING ENTITIES SO THAT'S JUST
WHAT WAS SET UP IN AB ONE AND IT
TWENTY SIX AT THE TIME OF THE
DISSOLUTION OF REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES.
AND WE A 100% -- JUST TO CLARIFY
A 100% OF THE TIME THAT OF THAT
LEGISLATION OF ANY BONDS THAT
WERE ISSUED FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CREATION COULD BE SPENT
ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING CREATION
WE HAD A THREE SERIES ISSUES AND
ONE ON THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE
SPENT FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECT.
THE WHAT WE'RE ASKING TODAY IS
FOR THE CAPITAL BONDS THE NON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FUNDS TO BE.
FOR DOUBLE HOUSING UNDER THE
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION ALL OF THE
FOR THE HOUSING BONDS COULD BE
USED FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
WITHIN IS MS BAKER'S CONCERN.
NOT NOT REALLY WARRANTED THAT
THERE'S NO JEOPARDY FOR ANY PROP
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING.
WELL I I THINK AND I CAN ANSWER
THAT FOR THE FUTURE BUT I I
THINK FOR THE CLIMATE RIGHT NOW
IN THE CITY WERE ALSO ACTUALLY
WORKING WITH OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT
FOR IF A BEFORE ELEVEN IS
APPROVED ACTUALLY SOME OF THE
FUNDING WILL BE USED TO CREATE.
A AFFORDABLE HOUSING A WORK
FORCE HOUSING FOR TEACHERS IN
OUR COMMUNITY SO WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH OUR LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICT ON THIS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU RESEARCHER.
YOU WANNA ADD IN ON THAT.
THERE ARE A CERTAINLY I
APPRECIATE THAT ATTEMPTS TO TRY
TO MITIGATE ANY NEGATIVE IMPACT --
TO OUR TO LOCAL SCHOOLS -- IN WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT THAT
IN THIS THERE HAVE BEEN
CONVERSATIONS TO TRY TO PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR TEACHERS --
AND IF WE COULD GET HIGHER PAY
FOR TEACHERS THAN THEY COULD.
AFFORD TO LIVE IN COMMUNITIESIN
WHICH THEY WORK WE'RE WORKING ON
THAT IT'S ON THE LIST OF ITEMS
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THERE COULD
POTENTIALLY BE AN IMPACT ON
LOCAL PROPERTY.
ARE TAX REVENUES FOR SCHOOLS SO
IF THAT ISN'T IT.
INCOME THAT POCKET ISN'T
COMPLETELY FILLED WHILE THE
INTENT WOULD BE TO TRY TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR TEACHERS TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IF AT THE END
OF THE DAY THAT MEANS THE
SCHOOLS.
DON'T HAVE ALL THE PROPERTY TAX
REVENUE THEY WOULD HAVE HAD
OTHERWISE.
THEY MIGHT NOT EVEN BE ABLE TO
KEEP ALL THE TEACHERS AND THAT
THEY'RE PROVIDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR SO UNFORTUNATELY
IT'S A CATCH TWENTY TWO
SITUATION THAT WE'RE NOT
COMFORTABLE BEING IN BUT
NEVERTHELESS WE'RE HERE TRYING
TO AT LEAST TO PROVIDE CONTEXT.
FOR THE SITUATION SO WE CAN ALL
TRY TO FIGURE OUT THE BEST WAY
TO MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH BOTH YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
CONVERSATION SENATOR BILL WOULD
YOU LIKE TO MAKE A MOTION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE DO HAVE A
MOTION FOR BY SENATOR BELL WE
LIKE TURN OVER TO SOMEONE OVER
FOR CLOSE.
THANK YOU I A DO YOU WANT TO ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE AND I THINK BASED ON THE
DISCUSSION YOU CAN SEE THAT
THERE REALLY IS VERY MINIMAL IF
ANY.
IMPACT ON PROP NINETY EIGHT THE
CONCERNS RAISED CLEARLY BY.
THEIR ADMISSION ARE SPECULATIVE
AND IN THIS CASE WERE NOT
BECAUSE OF THE SMALL AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
THE BENEFITS SCHOOLS BENEFIT TO
LOCAL TEACHERS WHO ARE IN FACT
SUPPORTING WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO
DO HERE I ASKED ABOUT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SOMEONE.
THIS MOTION IS BY THE COULD
CENTER FROM HEY IT HAS TO DO
PASSED TO SENATE HOUSING.
HENDERSON WINNER PERCENT CHESTER
BROKE UP PLEASE WIRE HI WHY I'M
MORE A LOT.
BELL BILL I HERTZBERG.
FIRST REGARD RICARDO.
RICARDO AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE SIXTY CURRENTLY
ENJOYS A SIX ZERO VOTE.
WE ARE GOING TO KEEP THAT ROLE
OPEN AT THIS TIME [inaudible]
YEAH.
WITH THE GERMAN.
WITH A DOUBLE HEADER.
ITEM NUMBER NINETY SIX EIGHTEEN
THIS IS ALSO SOME NEVER STONE.
HE IS BACK I APOLOGIZE TO US IN
THE WOMAN GARCIA [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SO AB SIX EIGHTEEN IS BEFORE YOU
AND WE'VE SEEN A NUMBER OF OF
BILLS LIKE THIS.
WE HAD ORIGINALLY STARTED THIS
FOR THE CITY THAT I LIVE IN
CITIES CUTS VALLEY AND RECENTLY
AMENDED IT TO INCLUDE.
CITY EMERYVILLE TO INCREASE
THEIR ABILITY TO GO TO THEIR
VOTERS AND ASK FOR A SALES AND
USE TAX INCREASE CUTS VALLEY HAS
IS IN THE UNENVIABLE POSITION OF
EVEN THOUGH IT'S IN A ERELI
WEALTHY AREA.
GIVEN THE CONSTRAINTS UNDER PROP
THIRTEEN AND AND THE TAX
STRUCTURES THAT HAVE COME THEY
ARE A LOW WELL CITY THEY GET A
VERY SMALL PERCENTAGE OF THEIR
PROPERTY TAX REVENUES AND RELY
HAVE TO RELY ON UNFORTUNATELY.
VERY REGRESSIVE MECHANISMS LIKE
INCREASING SALES TAXES IN ORDER
TO PROVIDE THE SERVICES THAT THE
CITY IS EXPECTING THEY ARE
CURRENTLY GOING THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS RIGHT NOW.
AND ANTICIPATE NEEDING TO GO OUT
TO THEIR VOTERS WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS GIVE THEM OF THE BEST
LOOKS ABILITY POSSIBLE TO THAT
THEY CAN.
ASK THE VOTERS WERE APPROPRIATE
NUMBER AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY
CAN CONTINUE TO FINANCE THE CITY
TO THE EXPECTATION OF THEIR
COMMUNITY THAT I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE AND I HAVE JACK TO IS.
THERE CITY OF SCOTTS VALLEY WITH
ME THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
SIMMONS MAYOR IT'S GOOD HAVING
COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
MAKING THE DRIVE UP.
GIVE TWO MINUTES SIR OKAY FOR
SOURCE THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
FIRST TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE
FOR AUTHORING AND CARING FOR
THIS BILL THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TO US -- I AM THE MAYOR SCOTT
VALLEY AND WE ARE ASKING FOR
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD ENABLE US
TO ASK OUR VOTERS.
IF THEY WOULD PAY MORE IN SALES
TAX FOR VITAL CITY SERVICES
SPECIFICALLY WE'RE ASKING YOU TO
PROVE.
AB SIX ONE EIGHT WHICH WOULD.
ALLOW OUR CITY TO IMPLEMENT UPON
VOTER APPROVAL.
A TRANSACTION IS USED TAX THAT
WOULD RATE THAT WOULD EXCEED THE
STATE CAP.
THAT'S WHY THE HISTORY PROVIDING
LEAN AND COST EFFECTIVE SERVICES
TO OUR RESIDENTS.
AND BUSINESSES HISTORICALLY --
ONCE CUTS BELLY IT'S ONLY WHEN
WE REALLY NEEDED MONEY FROM THE
COMMUNITY THAT WE'VE GONE OUT AS
FOR ATTACKS WE'VE DONE THAT
TWICE FOR A TEMPORARY
TRANSACTIONS AND USE TAXES IN.
200-052-00013 AND BOTH WERE
SOLIDLY APPROVED BY OUR
RESIDENTS OF SEVENTY ONE AND 75%.
WELL THE CITY HAS SOLD FINANCIAL
RESERVES RIGHT NOW WE DO HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT STRUCTURAL FINANCIAL
OPERATING DEFICIT.
AND WILL TAKE WHATEVER STEPS WE
HAVE TO TAKE BUT WE DON'T WANT
TO TO CUT OUR VITAL SERVICES IF
WE DON'T HAVE.
TO LAST YEAR THE CITY DID ADOPT
THE FISCAL SUSTAINABILITY PLAN A
TEN YEAR PLAN TO PROVIDE A PATH
TO THE FUTURE.
AND WHEN STANDARD AND POOR'S
RECENTLY OUT.
REVIEWED OUR REAFFIRMED OUR BOND
RATING.
THEY WERE -- THEY CITED
SPECIFICALLY THE DID REAFFIRM
AND THEY CITED SPECIFICALLY ARE
FISCAL SUSTAINABILITY PLAN ARE
STRONG MANAGEMENT AND A STRONG
RESERVES.
WE ALSO COMMITTEE TO APPROVE SB
SIX ONE EIGHT PROVIDES CUS WHY
VOTERS THE OPTION. TO REYES
TRANSACTIONS USE TAXES FOR THE
RESIDENTS WE HAVE THE BEST
OPPORTUNITY TO RECEIVE THE
SERVICES THEY EXPECT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
AMERICAN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
TAKING THE TIME TO BE HERE TODAY
WE NOW THINK THAT OPEN UP TO
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT THE
MORNING.
MORNING CHAIRPERSON MCGUIRE
NICOLO DELUCA HERE BEHALF THE
CITY OF EMERYVILLE ALWAYS A
PLEASURE TO BE BEFORE YOUR
COMMITTEE.
REALLY WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR ADDING US
WE'RE LAST MINUTE ADD.
VERY SIMILAR LAST YEAR WE'RE
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE WITH
ALMOST THE EXACT SAME THING FOR
THE CITY OF BERKELEY.
CITY OF EMERYVILLE IS
CONSIDERING A SALES TAX INCREASE
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY WERE CAPPED
OUT THIS WOULD BE FOR VITAL
PUBLIC SAFETY SERVICES AND ALSO
TO PROTECT OF OUR CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS AND RESOURCES.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS TO
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR THE
SUPPORT SO STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU DISEASE HERE THANK YOU SO
MUCH NOW LIKE VAN SEE THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF BILL
PIC PLEASE COME FOR THIS TIME.
LAST CALL NOW LIKE TURN OVER
THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED.
PLEASE COME FORWARD LAST CALL.
THAT TURNED OVER TO COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS MISS ROGER.
SHE CHARGES FOR MAKING
OBSERVATION BECAUSE WERE --
ENJOYING BUDGET SEASON -- AND I
HAVE THE PLEASURE OF SITTING ON
THE BUDGET CONFERENCE COMMITTEE.
AND I JUST WANNA MAKE THE
OBSERVATION THAT THE STATE HAS
TWENTY ONE AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS THAT WERE.
ENJOYING IS A SURPLUS BUT OUR
CITIES AND OUR COUNTIES IN OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
ARE STRUGGLING -- THE CITY'S
ONLY RECOURSE IS TO RAISE THE
SALES TAX -- ANY IT YET WORK
WERE FLASH.
AND I DON'T SEE I DON'T SEE
ANYBODY GOING TO CITIES A TOP
PROPOSAL.
TO MAYBE PUT SOME FOR BUT LEASE
PUT SOME FUNDING INTO THE CAL
STARS TO HELP REDUCE THE RATES.
FOR THE PENSION CONTRIBUTIONS
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS BUT IT IT
JUST SEEMS A LITTLE IRONIC THAT
WE'RE SO FLASH IN OUR CITIES ARE
COMING TO US. TO ASK FOR THE
ABILITY TO RAISE MORE TAXES --
SO I APPRECIATE THE MAYOR BEING
HONEST ABOUT HIS. TEN YEAR PLAN
I APPLAUD YOU FOR THAT BUT I
THINK MISTER CHAIR WE AS A
LEGISLATURE NEED TO LOOK AT THE
IMBALANCE.
IN THIS STATE.
THANK YOU.
IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE I THINK IT
IS IMPORTANT NOTE OTHERS TEN
BILLION MOVING FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OVER THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS FOR HOUSING AND HOMELESS
SERVICES A BILLION ALONE IS
PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET THANKS
FOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK.
THAT WOULD GO DIRECTLY TO CITIES
AND COUNTIES -- FOR HOMELESS IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE NEXT.
FISCAL YEAR SO I I HEAR WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING BUT THERE IS MONEY
FLOW AND AT TO CITIES IN THIS
WOULD HAVE TO BE APPROVED BY
LOCAL VOTERS IS WELL.
THAT SAID WOULD LIKELY TO SEE IF
WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE.
IS THERE SOMEONE OF ACTIVITIES
WOULD VANCE A MOTION AT THIS
TIME.
LOOKING FOR SOMEONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO ADVANCE
MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY THE AYE
CENTER WIENER THIS IS A DO
PASSED TO THE FLOOR MR CINNAMON
DO YOU LIKE CLOSER.
THANK YOU EN ACTUALLY I SHARE
YOUR VICE CHAIRS FRUSTRATION AND
WE HAVE A VERY BROKEN TAXATION
SYSTEM AND HAVE.%
START CITIES OF THEIR MOST
STABLE REVENUE BEING PROPERTY
TAXES SO THEY ARE FORCED TO GO
TO MUCH MORE REGRESSIVE
MECHANISMS WHICH ARE.
NOT ALWAYS THE EASIEST THING TO
PUSH THROUGH SO WE HAVE A VERY
DIFFICULT SITUATION THAT
BENEFITS THE STATE CURRENTLY.
WHEN SALES RECEIPTS ARE UP AND?
INCOME.
TAXES ARE WE'RE SEEING BENEFITS
FROM THOSE IN THOSE THOSE
PRIMARILY GO TO THE STATE BUT WE
HAS SYSTEMATICALLY REMOVED.
THAT LEVERS FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO BE ABLE TO
MANAGE THEIR FINANCES
UNFORTUNATELY AND SO THEY COME
BEGGING FOR US TO GIVE THEM JUST
A LITTLE BIT OF HELP.
ON SOMETHING THAT THEY KNOW THEY
DON'T REALLY WANT TO HAVE TO DO
AND THEY UNDERSTAND THE
AGGRESSIVE NATURE OF IT
UNFORTUNATELY REALLY GIVEN THEM
NO PLACE ELSE TO GO.
SO WITH THAT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABOUT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER SIMMONS
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER MAYOR
FOR BEING YEARS WELL.
LAYS IN GERMAN THIS AGAIN AS A
DO PASS THE FLOOR MOTION SENSORS
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
HI WHY I'M MORE LOCK.
I FELT I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
RICARDO [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
WIENER.
WE ARE AYE RIO CURRENTLY DO IS A
THREE ZERO VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP
THAT ROLE OPEN AND WILL ADD
FOLKS ON THIS REGIMEN COULD YOU
SEE SURVEY BECAUSE THAT IS A
MUCH.
THANKS FOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
TALK ABOUT WATER DISTRICTS WE'VE
TWO BILLS FOR YOU RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE A SINGLE WOMAN GARCIA
HERE.
SHE HAS TWO BILLS THAT ARE
COMING FORWARD.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AND ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE FIRST OF ALL WE'RE GONNA
BE.
TALKING ABOUT ALL ISSUES OF THE
CENTRAL BASIN MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT -- IN THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS AND WILL GO ON TO ITEM
TWELVE MADDEN.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
ITEM NUMBER SIX IN ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE BOTH HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
I WE WILL TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO
YOU ON ITEM NUMBER SIX AB FIVE
NINETY ONE WELCOME.
THANK YOU I AM HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS ON THE BILL.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN I
AUTHORED AB SEVENTEEN NINE
NINETY FOUR WHICH CREATED A NEW
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE FOR THE
CENTRAL BASE AND MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT -- TO ADDRESS SERIOUS
AT THE CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
CALIFORNIA AUDIT REPORT.
THE LIST IS LONG SINCE THEN THE
BASE AND HAS BEEN WORKING ON
REFORMS AND MOVING FORWARD.
AND ALONG THE WAY WE HAVE FOUND
THAT WE NEED TO CLARIFYING
LANGUAGE ON THE DEFINITION OF A
REPRESENTATIVE.
IN RESPONSE TO LITIGATION OVER
THE MEANING.
AND SO WE ARE HOPING THAT WITH
AB FIVE NINETY ONE THE FULL
INTENT OF THE ORIGINAL BILL IS
MATT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SOMEONE WHEN
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO OPEN UP
TO THOSE WHO MAY BE IN SUPPORT
GOOD AFTERNOON.
THE MORNING I GUESS MORNING
INNATE SOUL WITH THE ARMY OF THE
CENTRAL BASE A MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THANK THANK YOU SO MUCH WOULD
LIKE TO GO TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL PEAK PLEASE COME FORWARD.
WE HAVE MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY A
SINNER TITLE WATCH OUT.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED
[inaudible]
XENON.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
REMEMBER THERE IS NO COMMENT OR
QUESTION FROM THE VICE.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION THIS IS A DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO A
APPROPRIATION WHO WOULD LIKE
THERE TO MAKE THAT MOTION.
CENTRE BELL WAY I'M SORRY I
APOLOGIZE SIR TITLE THAT IS MY
BAD SHE'S ALREADY ALL OVER IT WE
DO HAVE A MOTION TO PASS AS A
MAJOR CORPORATIONS.
DISCUSS THE WHAT WHICH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU SO MUCH ASSEMBLY WOMAN
AFRAID FOR THE HERE MISSING JUST
RECALL PLEASE WIRE HI WHY I'M
MORE A LOT.
MORE LIKE AYE BELL.
BILL AYE HERTZBERG.
HER TITLE YOUR TOTAL AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER -- I SIX ALL
RIGHT THAT IT CURRENTLY ENJOYS A
SIX YEAR VOTE FOR GIVE THAT ROLE
OPEN.
LAYS IN GENERAL COMMITTEE WERE
NUMBER NINE ITEM TWELVE A. B.
TWELVE TWENTY WE DO A BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL.
CINNAMON FORESHORES.
WITHOUT A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY
THE AD CENTER TITLE I SOME WOMEN
HAVE YOU JUST BRIEFLY DESCRIBE
THE BILL PLEASE.
YES WE ARE JUST ENSURING THAT
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE THAT ARE
HIGHLY DEVELOPED AND URBAN
COMMUNITIES -- CONTINUE TO HAVE
ADEQUATE REPRESENTATION ON THE
MOUNT METROPOLITAN BOARD -- AND
THEY KEEP THE NUMBER SEIZE THE
CURRENTLY HAVE.
INSIDE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
WATCH OUT I LIKE IT THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE NOW WOULD LIKE THAT OPEN
UP TO ANYONE WHO LIKE THEIR
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
GERMAN WHO'D LIKE TO GET TO GO
FIRST YOU DO A BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
THEY TOLD WILL HAVE EVER OF THE
BOTTOM WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT
CONSIDERATION THANKS SO MUCH
GOOD MORNING.
MORNING CHEN WIRE MEMBERS OF
MANY JOBS OF THE GAS BILL
[inaudible]
WATER DISTRICT.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SEE FOR LEADERSHIP ON HER
COMMITMENT TO GOOD GOVERNANCE
AND SERVING THE CITY'S
COMMITTEES SERVED BY SUCH BASE
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT.
OUR SERVICE AREA IS HOME TO ONE
POINT SIX MILLION RESIDENTS MANY
COMMUNITIES AS WELL -- OPENS
WORKING CLASS NEARLY 50% AB
TWELVE TWENTY WOULD PRESERVE OUR
REGION'S REPRESENTATION ON THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS MUCH PAUL
WATER DISTRICT BOARD OF
DIRECTORS.
WILL ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
MEDICAL WATER DISTRICT DIRECTORS
FOR THEIR AND THEIR TEAM FOR
THEIR SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE
TWENTY IS HER TODAY.
AND I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANKS FOR
BEING HERE TODAY YOU.
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF ANYONE ELSE
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF BILL GOOD MORNING MA'AM --
FOR SOME LASSEN ORGANIZATION YES
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN CHOIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
CATHY VIA TELL I AM WITH
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WE WANT TO
THANK THE CENTRAL BASIN FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THIS APPROACH
TO THEIR THEIR NEEDS.
AND WE ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
MEMBER FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE IS THAT WE SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
BUT I COULD SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL BE PLEASE COME FOR THIS
TIME.
SEENOW I WOULD LIKE TO GO TO
SEE IF THERE IS ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION IT COULD PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
CURRENCY NO OPPOSITION WE DO
HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY
CENTER TYLER THIS IS A DO PASSED
MOTION TO THE FLOOR ANY
QUESTIONS COME [inaudible]
TIME.
CURRENCY NINE SOMEONE YOU LIKE
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
ISN'T JUST WORKING PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL WIRE HI.
I'M MORE A LOT MORE LIKE I BILLS.
THEY'LL AYE HERTZBERG FURTADO.
YOUR TOTAL AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER WIENER AYE.
I CURRENTLY DO IS SIX YEAR VOTE
ONE KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN BECAUSE
HERTZBERG IS NOT HERE SO WE'LL
COME BACK TO THAT.
WITH GREAT BILL COMING UP THIS
IS ITEM NUMBER EIGHT A. B. SIX
FOURTEEN EGGMAN.
FOCUSING ON ALL ISSUES OF FOOD
BANKS.
GRATEFUL FOR HER CONTINUED FOCUS
ON THIS.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN WE DO HAVE.
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON YOUR BILL
TODAY AND TASTIC -- MY GOSH
SITTER TACOS ON FIRE WATCH OUT
WE GOT A MOTION ON THE FLOOR.
THIS IS A DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
SENATE PREPARATIONS -- SOMEONE
IT WOULD YOU LIKE TO GIVE US A
BRIEF DESCRIPTION THE BILL PRICE
CERTAINLY WOULD.
AB SIX FOURTEEN DOES TWO THINGS
PROVIDES ANOTHER AVENUE FOR
FARMERS TO BE ABLE TO DONATE.
AB SUPPLIES TO FOOD BANKS.
THE AD DIDN'T PROVIDES THEN --
FOOD FOOD FOOD BANKS FOR FOR
PEOPLE LATELY WE WASTE. SIX
MILLION TONS OF FOOD.
A YEAR IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AT THE SAME TIME WE
HAVE SIX MILLION.
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE FOOD INSECURE.
AS WE CONTINUE TO CHIP AWAY AT
THIS PROBLEM BOTH EXPANDING THAT --
TAX CREDIT AS WELL AS EXPANDING
WHAT CAN BE DONATED RIGHT NOW
IT'S JUST FRESH FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES BUT WE BELIEVE DAIRY
MILK AND OTHER KINDS OF NON
PERISHABLE SHOULD ALSO BE
INCLUDED IN THAT.
AND THAT IS A PRECISELY WHAT
THIS BILL DOES WE ARE REDUCING
WASTE PROVIDING AVENUES.
FOR FARMERS TO BE ABLE TO DONATE
AND PROVIDING FRESH FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES AND ADDITIONAL
SUPPLIES TO FOOD BANKS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE HIM GOOD BILL THINK SO MUCH
IN A SIMILAR WHEN YOU'RE GONNA
BE TAKING THE I AM TAKING THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND I THINK
YOU. FOR WORKING WITH THE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE NOT A
TURN OVER THOSE WHOLIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL YOU
DO A BY PARTICIPANTS.
THANK YOU NONE CHAIR MISTER
MEMBERS ENTER SHANE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS -- WITH THAT DONE THE HAVE
ANYTHING FURTHER TO ADD JUST
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT TO
ENDING HUNGER.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS BONNIE
MANUAL FROM CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
WASTE.
I'M JUST KEEP IT SHORT AND SWEET
A CALIFORNIA DATA SHOWS THAT
FOOD WAYS IS MOST PREVALENT ITEM
IN OUR LANDFILLS AND ACCOUNTS
420% OF ALL METHANE EMISSIONS IN
CALIFORNIA.
SB SIX FOURTEEN WOULD NOT ONLY
PROVIDE FARMERS WITH THE COST
BENEFITS ARE COST SAVINGS THAT
WOULD BE REINVESTED IN THEIR
ASSETS.
BUT BENEFIT THE ENVIRONMENT BY
CUTTING DOWN CALIFORNIA'S
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS THANK
YOU THANKS FOR BEING HERE WE'RE
NOT GONNA.
ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT FIRST LAST
ORGANIZATION A GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MATTHEW
ON WITH WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION WE'RE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU SEE
THINK SO MUCH.
LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT.
HERE AND SEE NUMBER NOW LIKE
TURN OVER THOSE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSED.
THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING ALL RIGHT
WE'RE HAVE BRINGING IT BACK
WE DO HAVE A MOTION BY CENTER
TYLER THIS IS A DO PASSES A
MINUTE TOO SOON APROPRIATIONS
THAT WOULD LIKE.
TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS CENTER ABOUT.
I GUESS ONE OF THE ASSEMBLY
PROUD THAT MY ONE OF A MEMBER OF
MY SENATE STAFF IS THE PRESIDENT
OF THE SACRAMENTO FOOD BANK.
AND SUPPORT FOR THIS I LIKE TO
REACTIVE IN THE THANK YOU SO
MUCH CENTER ABOUT VERY GRATEFUL
FOR THAT AND PLEASE PASS ON OUR
THANKS AS WELL ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS A THEIR
AGO.
BY SHARE COME ON NOW.
I LIKE IT.
ALL RIGHT.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION TO FORM
SOMEONE LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
MISSING CHESTER CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL CHOIR HI WHY I
BORE A LOT MORE LIKE AYE BELL.
THEY'LL AYE HERTZBERG FURTADO.
YOUR TOTAL AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER WIENER AYE.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A SIX ZERO VOTE
WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN
THANK YOU SO MUCH THE MEMBER.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST SEVEN THE
BEST FOR LAST LATE IS A GENERAL
NUMBER.
ITEM NUMBER TEN THIS IS AB.
EIGHTY FIVE SILLIMAN IT'S ALWAYS
WONDERFUL TO SEE YOU HAVE BEEN
DOING.
WELCOME TO COMMITTEE THE FLOOR
IS YOURS IN THE GOOD NEWS IS
YOUR BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ALL
RIGHT IF OH MY GOSH HURTADO IS
ROLLING.
I LIKE IT -- IN IF YOU DON'T
MIND PLEASE -- I BRIEFLY
DESCRIBE THE BILL ALL RIGHTS --
AB EIGHT EIGHT FIVE WILL HELP
VICTIMS OF THE CALIFORNIA
WILDFIRES GET BACK ON THEIR FEET
BY PROVIDING MUCH NEEDED NEEDED
PROPERTY TAX RELIEF THE THOMAS
FIRE IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN RESULTED IN
THIRTEEN HUNDRED STRUCTURES --
DESTROYED OR DAMAGED IT WAS TH
MOST DESTRUCTIVE FIRE IN THE
STATE HISTORY UNTIL TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WHEN THE MENDOCINO
COMPLEX CAMP BUTTE.
AND WILL THE FIRES DECIMATED
THOUSANDS MORE HOMES AND
BUSINESSES.
CURRENTLY IF SOMEBODY LOSES
THEIR HOME IN A NATURAL DISASTER
THEY CAN TRANSFER THE PROPERTY
TAX LIABILITY TO ANOTHER
LOCATION WITHIN THE SAME COUNTY
SO LONG AS IT IS DEEMED
SUBSTANTIALLY EQUIVALENT.
AB EIGHT EIGHT FIVE WOULD
PROVIDE THE SAME TAX RELIEF TO
THE ORIGINAL PIECE OF LAND BY
CREATING CONFORMITY.
WITH OTHER AREAS OF PROPERTY TAX
LAW EIGHT EIGHT FIVE WILL HELP
THOSE WHO HAVE LOST EVERYTHING
AND ARE STRUGGLING TO REBUILD
THEIR LIVES WITH ME TODAY'S
REPRESENTATIVE FROM OUR SPONSOR
THE CALIFORNIA ASSESSORS
ASSOCIATION.
IT'S A GREAT BILL THANK YOU SOME
LIMóN PLEASE STAND.
AS WELL SIR YES GOOD MORNING
JESSE SALINAS YOLO COUNTY
ASSESSOR I AM BY CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSESSORS ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AND WE WANT TO THANK
THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN IRWIN FOR HER
LEADERSHIP AND PUT PUTTING THIS
TOGETHER WE WE HAD A ROBUST
CONVERSATION AT THE FALL MEETING
OF ASSESSORS.
AND WE LOOKED AT WHAT WAS
HAPPENING WITH ALL THE FIRES
THAT WERE TAKING PLACE AND WE
REALIZE WE REALLY NEED TO DO
SOMETHING.
AND IDENTIFIED THE NEED TO HAVE
SOME UNIFORMITY IN TERMS OF
SUBSTANTIALLY EQUIVALENT --
VERBIAGE THAT THAT NEEDED TO
HELP US PROVIDE THE SUPPORT THAT
WE NEEDED IN THE ADD TO THESE
INDIVIDUALS AND AS WAS NOTED --
AND HER PRESENTATION IS THAT
THERE WAS INCONSISTENCIES ABOUT
ALLOWING PEOPLE TO USE THE SAME
PLOT OF LAND TO REBUILD AND IT
WAS JUST THAT.
A GAP THAT EXISTED IN WE'RE
EXCITED THAT THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION WITH BECAUSE VERY
POSITIVE IN MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION OR STRONG SUPPORT OF
IT THANK YOU.
WELL IN APPRECIATE BRING THIS
FORWARD MR LOUIS BROWN IS IN THE
HOUSE MISS BROWN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
OF THE COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS
INSTITUTE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
ACTION COMMITTEE.
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
THANKS SO MUCH.
SADDAM IS BACK.
BUT MR REMEMBERS COMMITTEE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT SO SEE.
YOUR SUPPORT THINKS IS A GREAT
IDEA AND A GOOD BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH ISDONE WOULD
LIKE TO GET A SEAT IS ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL TO
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
CURRENCY NUMBER NOW THAT WOULD
BRING FORTY ONE WHO'S IN
OPPOSITION.
HEARING SEE NOW WOULD LIKE TO
TURN OVER TO COMMITTEE.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
MINISTER DID YOU ALREADY HAVE
YES WE DID AS WE DO HAVE A
MOTION FOR BY CENTER DOT OF THIS
IS DUE PASS OUR PREPARATIONS
ESALEN WHEN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THAT CLASS FOR SUPPORT THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISSING JUST RECALL
PLEASE WIRE HI WHERE I AM OR
LOCK.
WELL LIKE I BILL.
WELL I HERTZBERG RICARDO.
HELLO I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER.
EARLY TO A SIX YEAR VOTE WE'RE
GONNA BE TRACKING DOWN THIS
HERTZBERG AND WILL ADD HIM ON
JUST A BIT THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
ONE THING I MUCH SENATE CAN
SUCCESSOR -- VISITADO IN
ABSENTIA WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO OUR AWARD FOR TODAY
[inaudible]
IT OFF [inaudible] FOR THANK YOU
THAT'S A GREAT HONOR THANK YOU
SO MUCH IT'S AMAZING.
THANK YOU I WILL MAKE SURE THAT
HE RECEIVED HIS AWARD FOR NOT
EVEN REALLY SHOWING UP TODAY SO
WHAT I THINK.
YEAH FOR A MINUTE THAT'S RIGHT A
MINUTE.
BLAZING CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE WE'RE GONNA GET OUR
ACT TOGETHER -- INSERT ADDED ON
FOLKS WHO NEED TO BE -- ENTER
INTO THE ROLE GIVE US ABOUT
SIXTY SECONDS.
I AM ELEVEN THAT WAS CONSENT.
HOW WAS IT -- NO WE DO HAVE ONE
MORE HIDING I APOLOGIZE ITEM
ELEVEN YES.
IT NEVER GOT WHAT WE ADD FOLKS
ON THE VICE CHAIR IS ALL OVER IT --
WERE AS WE ARE CHECKING ANDERSON
THE WOMAN INCOME LONGER DOES
WE'RE GOING TO ADD FOLKS ON HERE
REAL QUICK THIS GIVES A MOMENT.
WE'RE GONNA START WITH CONSENT
TO ITEM NUMBER SEVEN WE'RE GONNA
NEED TO ADD ON SENATOR WIENER
AND SENATOR BELL -- MISSING
CHESTER [inaudible]
THE REBEL.
BELL I WIENER.
WIENER I HAVE -- SIX ZERO SIX
ZERO CIVIL.
BUT CURRENTLY SIX ZERO WHAT
WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB THIRTY SEVEN
THIS IS A DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
SENATE PREPARATIONS.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FOUR ONE VOTE
MISSING CHESTER NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO ROOM.
FOR ITEM NUMBER ONE AB.
THIRTY SEVEN SO THIS IS A
FOURTEEN YEAR.
AND THE STORE [inaudible] FOR
ONE ONE NOW.
OKAY -- IF THE BASE OPERATING SO
THAT. FOUR FIVE SIX OKAY THE
SUPPORT LINE [inaudible] FOR ONE
YEAH [inaudible]
YES.
THAT IS GOING TO ENJOY A FOUR
ONE VOTE WE'RE GONNA WAIT FOR
CENTER HERTZBERG GIVE US A
MOMENT WE'RE GOING TO JUST PULL
THE BILLS TO SEE WHICH ONES WE
HAVE FOLKS MISSING ON JUST GIVE
US A MOMENT [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HERTZBERG
[inaudible]
THIS [inaudible]
THIRTEEN NUMBER.
THIRTEEN BUT IS IN GERMAN
EVERYTHING ELSE IS OUR AWARD
WINNER TODAY BUT EXCEPT ITEM
THIRTEEN ITEM THIRTEEN THIS IS
AB SIXTEEN OH FIVE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
TRANSPORTATION.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A TWO ONE VOTE
MISS LANCHESTER CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS L..
L. AYE HERTZBERG WIENER.
WIENER HI.
THAT CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FOR A
ONE VOTE WE ARE WILLING TO KEEP
THAT ROLE OPEN AN ADD ON MR
HERTZBERG IN JUST A BIT
[inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
FIVE LADIES
IN GERMAN WE'RE GONNA GO BACK TO
ITEM NUMBER FIVE THAT'S AB.
FOR ELEVEN MACHINE IS A DO
PASSED TO SENATE HOUSING MISLAID
CHESTER NIELSEN.
NIELSEN ITEM NO.
FIVE THAT IS A FIVE EIGHT ZERO
VOTE THE VOTE.
THAT MAKES IT A FIVE ONE FIVE
ONE OKAY. FIVE ONE VOTE. FIVE
ONE VOTE IN WE ARE GOING TO
CLOSE THAT ROLL DOWN AND THAT
VOTE IS FINAL AND ITEM NUMBER
.
FIVE PLEASE IN GERMAN WE WAITING
FOR ONE OFF WE HAVE ONE
ADDITIONAL BILL LAUGHED IT'S A
CLIFFHANGER -- SENATOR ANY ITEMS
YOU'D LIKE TO BE TO DISCUSS AT
THIS TIME.
YEAH EXACTLY HI DAY [inaudible]
OUR MISTER VICE CHAIR
[inaudible]
GOOD [inaudible]
EVEN.
NOT EVEN LIVING THE DREAM OF
BUDGET.
A THEIR AGO NICE WORK CLOSER.
MY CONCERNS ARE.
I JUST.
YOU SEE THE GLASS IS HALF FULL
AND JUST I FEEL SORRY FOR THE
CITIES.
THAT HAD TO COME HERE AND ASK
FOR TAX.
INCREASE FIRMWARE FLASH.
AND FIGHTING OVER WHAT KIND OF
PORK TO SEND THEM TO OUR
DISTRICT.
SORRY NO NOTHING TO APOLOGIZE
FOR I'M GRATEFUL.
BUT WE DO HAVE A TRADITION HERE
OH MY GOODNESS.
HEY FIND THE LATEST JIM.
SHE IS IN A HOUSE.
WE ARE WELCOMING.
THESE IN THE WOMAN TO COMMITTEE.
THE LAST AND FINAL BILL TODAY
HIGH DATING -- MADAM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THIS IS AB ELEVEN HOME
ELEVEN HUNDRED THE FLOOR IS
YOURS IN GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
SENATORS APOLOGIES FOR THE DELAY --
I DO WANT TO LET YOU ALL KNOW
THAT WE HAVE GRACIOUSLY ACCEPTED
THAT COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS I AM
PRESENTING AB ELEVEN HUNDRED
WHICH WILL ALLOW A LINE THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING CODES.
BUT LOCAL PARKING ORDINANCES TO
SUPPORT ELECTRIC VEHICLE OR EVEY
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE.
IN AB CHARGING STATION IS
INSTALLED AT A PARKING SPACE THE%
BUILDING CODE DEFINES EXPLICITLY
THAT IT IS A CHARGING SPOT AND
NO LONGER A PARKING SPOT.
SOME LOCALITIES HAVE BEEN
INTERPRETING THE LAW TO SAY THAT
YOU EITHER NEED ONE OR THE OTHER
AND THIS.
LAW WOULD CLARIFY AND ALSO
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY FOR THOSE LOCALITIES.
BUILDING AN ADDITIONAL PARKING
SPACES OFTEN COSTLIER
TECHNICALLY UNFEASIBLE CAUSING
CHARGING PROJECTS TO BE DROPPED
ENTIRELY WE KNOW THAT SOME
MUNICIPALITIES INCLUDING SOME NO
MAN SACRAMENTO COUNTIES AND THE
CITIES OF STOCKTON IN LA HAVE
RECOGNIZE THIS.
OR VACATION BUT THIS WOULD MAKE
THOSE CLARIFICATIONS STATEWIDE.
WE NEED TO HELP COMMUNITIES
ACCESS THIS IMPORTANT TECHNOLOGY
TO INCREASE CONSUMER CONFIDENCE
IN E. VIS.
AB ELEVEN HUNDRED HELPS ACHIEVE
THIS BY CLARIFYING THAT PARKING
STALLS WITH EVEY CHARGING
STATIONS CAN STILL COUNT TOWARDS
PARKING REQUIREMENTS.
AND WOULD ALSO ALLOW THE AND
ACCESSIBLE EVEY SPACES TO COUNT
AS TWO PARKING SPACES FOR THE
PURPOSES OF COMPLYING WITH THE
PARKING REQUIREMENT.
TODAY WITH ME AND SUPPORT IS
COREY BULLIS WITH THE ELECTRIC%
VEHICLE CHARGING ASSOCIATION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SCRIBBLES ON BEHALF OF
THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
ASSOCIATION OUR MEMBERS DESIGN
MANUFACTURE AND INSTALL -- EVEY
CHARGING EQUIPMENT AND SERVICES
MOST OF OUR MEMBERS ARE
HEADQUARTERED HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THE STATE HAS A GOAL TO
DEPLOY TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND EVEY CHARGING STATIONS
BY.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE HOWEVER TO
DATE WE ONLY HAVE ABOUT TWENTY
THOUSAND WELL SHORT OF OUR GOALS --
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER POINTED
OUT AVAILABILITY OF CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE IS KEY TO
ACTUALLY INCREASING CONSUMER --
CONFIDENCE IN AN UPTAKE OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
SCORES OF VIABLE CHARGING
PROJECTS EACH YEAR DUE TO THESE
TECHNICAL ISSUES OF THE BUILDING
CODE RUBBING UP AGAINST --
PARKING COUNTS -- BECAUSE OF THE
ADDED CONSTRUCTION COSTS THE
PROJECTS JUST DON'T PENCIL OUT
ECONOMICALLY.
OR IT IS LITERALLY PHYSICALLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO COMPLY WITH HAVING
TO UILD AN ADDITIONAL PARKING
SPOT BECAUSE THE SPACE IS
COMPLETELY BUILT OUT -- THIS IS
AN ISSUE THAT'S NOT UNIQUE TO
ONE CITY OR COUNTY IT'S A IT'S A
STATEWIDE ISSUE BUT AS POINTED
OUT THERE ARE MANY JURISDICTIONS
THAT HAVE PASSED ORDINANCES TO
FIX THIS ISSUE.
HOWEVER THOSE -- THOSE
MUNICIPALITIES ARE IN THE
MINORITY SO WE'D LIKE TO MAKE
THIS A STATEWIDE POLICY AND TO
FIX IT FOR ALL COMMUNITIES.
THE END RESULT IS MANY PLACES
THAT OUR PRIME LOCATION FOR
INSTALLING AN EEVEE CHARGING
STATION BECOME MISSED
OPPORTUNITIES. TO PROVIDE
COMMUNITIES AND EVEY DRIVERS
ACCESS TO MORE CHARGERS TO THE
DETRIMENT OF OUR STATE GOALS.
FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANKYOU THANK YOU FOR COMING
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING NOT HER MOMMA WITH
OTHER CALIFORNIA ELECTED
TRANSPORTATION COALITION IN
SUPPORT.
MICHAEL AFTER THE PRAYER AND
KAYLEE ON LARGE POINT IN SUPPORT.
MANY LEE ON BEHALF OF TESLA AND
IN SUPPORT.
ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF CAL STAR
THE MORNING LARISSA SAYS BUT
IT'S ON BEHALF OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON IN SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE LINE UP TO THE BACK OF
THE ROOM. ONE OF THE TIME.
I HAVE A MOTION.
DO WE HAVE ANY DISCUSSION FOR MY
COLLEAGUES [inaudible]
LINDA.
MADAM SECRETARY LET'S CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
MORE LOCK.
I LIKE AYE BELL.
BELL AYE HERTZBERG RICARDO.
THE TOTAL AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO WINNER.
WE ARE I REQUIRED YOU HAVE.
FOUR ONE THE PASSES FOR ONE BUT
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN.
THE ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
COLLEAGUES I I NEED TO RUN.
I HAVE VOTED.
WELL WHEN.
CENTER HERTZBERG.
ARRIVES IF SOMEONE TO TAKE OVER
[inaudible]
THAT RESPONSIBILITY -- AND BILL
TO SAY THAT
[inaudible]
ONE ALL
RIGHT
GONNA MOVE BACK TO ITEM
ELEVEN THIS IS AB ELEVEN HUNDRED
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO TRANSPORTATION.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS MISS LANCASTER
WIRE I HERTZBERG.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FIVE ONE VOTE
WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN
AND BE BACK WITH YOU IN JUST A
BIT
.
YEAH WE'RE GONNA BE OVER THE
ROLE WE GET THE MAJORITY LEADER
HERE IS ITEM NUMBER NINE MAYBE
SIX EIGHTEEN THIS IS A DO PASSED
THE FLOOR MOTION CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE ZERO CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AS MANCHESTER.
BURKE.
I HERTZBERG HI. FOUR ZERO FOUR
ZERO THAT BILL IS -- THAT'S IT
AT THAT BILL IS OUT WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE GIVE US ONE MORE MINUTE
AND WE'LL GET EVERYTHING ELSE
READY [inaudible]
THIS CALL.
ARE THEY SEE GENERAL NOW GOING
TO GO THROUGH OUR AGENDA IN AND
JUST CALL -- CALLED THE BILLS
HERE WE'RE GONNA START WITH OUR
CONTINUE COUNTER ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN THIS IS A DO PASTOR
PREPARATIONS -- CURRENTLY VOTE
IS SIX ZERO THAT IS OUR FINAL
VOTE IN THAT BILL IS OUT WE'RE
CLOSING THE ROLE.
WHEN I JUMP BACK TO ITEM NUMBER
ONE A. B. THIRTY SEVEN THIS IS
DO PASSES AMENDED SENATE
PREPARATIONS [inaudible]
CURRENT LOTUS.
VOTE IS FOR ONE THIS IS THE
FINAL VOTE THE BILL IS OUT WE'RE
CLOSE IN THE ROLE.
NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWO
EIGHTY TWO ELEVEN THIS HAS.
AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS MOTION.
CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE ZERO WE'D
THAT IT'S GONNA BE OUR FINAL
VOTE FOR CLOSING ALL.
ITEM NUMBER THREE EIGHTY THREE
OH EIGHT THIS IS A MOTION TO DO
PASSES AMENDED TO VETERANS
AFFAIRS CURRENT VOTE IS.
SIX ZERO THIS IS OUR FINAL VOTE
WE'RE NOW CLOSE IN THE THE BILL
IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB THREE TWO
ONE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO PREPARATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS SIX ZERO THAT IS
OUR FINAL VOTE THE BILL IS OUT
WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE
.
ALL RIGHT PARTY BEFORE NOW
MOVING ON A FILE ITEM SIX THIS
IS AB FIVE NINE ONE SAYS A
MOTION IS DO PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS SIX ZERO THIS IS
THE FINAL VOTE.
THE BILL IS OUT WHAT ROLE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE'RE NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TEN IT
SAYS A DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS OF MOTION.
CURRENT VOTE IS SIX ZERO THIS IS
OUR FINAL VOTE THE BILL IS OUT
AND WE'RE CLOSED ON THE ROLE.
FILE ITEM.
TWELVE AB.
TWELVE TWENTY THIS MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE FLOOR CURRENT VOTE
IS SIX ZERO THIS IS THE FINAL
VOTE THE BILL IS OUT FOR CLOSING
THE ROLE.
I APOLOGIZE THEY WERE JUMPING
AROUND A LITTLE BIT WE'RE JUST
MAKING SURE THAT YOU ARE STAYING
AWAKE WE NOW ON TO FILE ITEM.
EIGHT AB SIX FOURTEEN THIS
CURRENT VOTE IS SIX ZERO AS A DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
PREPARATIONS THIS IS THE FINAL
VOTE SIX ZERO THE BILL IS OUT.
THE CLOSER ROLE.
WE HAVE TWO MORE BILLS LEFT ITEM
ELEVEN AN ITEM THIRTEEN FIRST
ITEM.
ELEVEN AB.
ELEVEN HUNDRED THIS HAS A MOTION
TO DO PASS AS AMENDED YOU
TRANSPORTATION.
KERN VOTE IS.
FIVE ONE THIS IS THE FINAL VOTE
THE BILL IS OUT WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE.
FINALLY THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PATIENCE ITEM THIRTEEN A. B.
SIXTEEN OH FIVE THE MOTION IS DO
IS AMENDED TO SENATE
TRANSPORTATION.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS FOR ONE THIS
IS THE FINAL VOTE WE'RE CLOSING
THE ROLE THE BILLS OUT
[inaudible]
VEHICLES WILL
.
BUT IS GERMAN WE HAVE ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED BILLS COMING OUR WAY
OVER THE NEXT FIVE WEEKS -- SO --
PLEASE PLAN ON BRINGING SLEEPING
BAGS NOT NEXT WEEK BUT THE WEEK
AFTER FOR SURE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THIS MEANS YOU'RE IN GREAT JOB
TO THAT THE IN FIVE STAFF